told
[Applause]
[Music]
you
perfect
[Music]
perfect perfect hello what's up guys I
am Tomas dop as YOLO whatever you want
to call me welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast I'm with my co-host Marty
O'Neal we're back you scared me I know
you don't hear that but that scared me
we're back back in the building first
solo up I didn't expect that at all
let's go um it's a dope as usual podcast
you're talking about life drugs problems
accomplishments and everything in
between we are back it has been
officially 6 weeks since we've done a
solo episode a month and a half it's
Marty's birthday the last time we were
in this room with just me and you it's
October you shot Omar with the confetti
can oh I shot Omar in the chest with a
confetti cannon that's true I don't know
if you guys saw that part but I messed
up and I put a like a little dent in the
roof when I shot the other
one shouldn't have shot him with it I
could have took his teeth out didn't
think about that g Master lens
out yeah that too I was more worried
about his teeth cuz then I got to hear
him complain about it while I have to
fix it like I'm so sorry you know what
I'm saying oh yes things that don't get
said on the show I wish we could talk
about it's a lot funnier a lot of the
stuff we say is slap your knee funny but
it might be considered kind of offensive
a little bit we're talking about we have
new cameras guys and as you can see the
whites are very crisp the blacks are
very crisp like they're and like all
they're separated like the camera
segregated the colors and he goes yeah
it's segregation we finally got
segregation down of our cameras and then
Marty says I have a new album coming out
called white balance white
balance yo all the camera guys out there
are going nuts laughing their asses off
everybody else like what
anyway I thought it was funny Kell just
segregated this is white this is black
imagine a fence and there's a concert
over here going in the ' 50s we've
segregated the colors very nicely MH and
that's the kind of [__] that gets you
did anybody notice the new cameras
seamlessly come into the equation during
these guest episodes anybody notice we
got four brand new cameras guys brand
new this one bomb that one bomb this one
bomb and they're not dying wait that's
three am I burnt didn't we buy four
technically your camera still pretty
new Oh I thought we bought four of those
we got three we got three new ones boom
boom boom there we go yo I I I'm I'm off
I'm off the chain today I'm I was about
to say some stupid
[__] but I won't can we do a quick recap
uh of everything we've been doing was it
Will Sasso that kicked off this no Sasso
then we went evil Deeds then we went the
birthday episode okay then we went
fluffy which was epic if you guys didn't
know we have a Tik Tok Marty posted a
clip of fluffy staring at the Joint it
got 3 and a half million views on just
the picture crazy got 30,000 followers
fluffy holding the
cannon so we got fluffy the next week we
had cheich which was
awesome it's pretty sick pretty wild
it's pretty wild would we just say about
him oh yeah
the oh yes the old man like when the
bill comes you hit him with the Uno C
you pick up the bill reverse when you're
when you're old you could do stupid [__]
and people go what a funny old man but
if I do that they like what a piece of
[__] cheap [__] put the reverse card
on the winner got you man you smell like
weed fo you're not going to pay for your
a guys are got [__] you guys are
dabbing at the table you got old with
the reverse when you're old sexual
harassment is just oh how cute but when
you're 32 the same thing's at 72 you
going to jail
interesting remember what was
it
Wedding Singer with old man grabs Drew
Barrymore's butt and he high fives his
grandson they're like y That's a salt
Bad Grandpa show that's a salt bad
Grandpa's a good movie Bad Grandpa's
good dirty Grandpa Isn't that with uh
Robert Jiro yeah that show was kind of
funny Zack Efron is not just a like uh
the pretty kid he's pretty funny man
pretty he's got he's got that American
Dad chin going on right now he got a
surgery it looks weird but he's got the
American Dad chin going on but on his
chin yeah did you see did you guys see
this I saw an interview with Zack e you
know the pretty kid have you seen his
chin uh it's like give me a movie zackon
Zack I don't know what other movies is
he in bad neighbors bad neighbors okay
okay okay okay that guy the pretty kid
look at his most recent picture Marty it
is going to drive you insane look at his
job God look at his job bro why he said
he was drinking at home woke up next to
to a counter with his jaw hanging off
what oh he said he was running around
his house Slip and hit a countertop bust
his jaw open he said he woke up covered
in blood and his jaw was hanging oh no
oh God I don't know how real that
is you wouldn't do that on purpose but
if you did and you come with that story
now people are like damn you should have
said I'm Mickey Ro and I was I've been
underground boxing and you know I just
had to fix the CH it would have been
harder than like I was drinking Soo
slipped in my socks my chin ripped off I
put my chin off it's sad dude he was
like the prettiest kid in Hollywood now
it's like I mean he's still now he just
looks like yo I'm a soldier in every
movie like I will rescue you know what I
mean he looks like yeah it looks like he
like a a widening versus like an injury
it looks like he looks like American Dad
yeah yeah exactly a big American CIA
agent he should be protect the president
now before being the president's son now
he protects the President it's like a
what happened where did we go
off what happened why are we doing this
we're we're talking about him for some
[__] reason oh we're talking about
Che and then we said oh Old man dirty
grandpa dirty Grandpa Zack Efron
chin spider web okay um it is hot in
hell it's hot in here um so here we go
continue we had cheich and then right
after we had John Hash House episode
went four hours got age restricted on
the upload so please go watch that
episode I don't know how that happened I
mean I know how it happened I just
people been waiting for that one it's
like damn people are still saying this
came out mhm it's okay anyway uh after
that we had Benny The Butcher which was
epic super epic awesome episode I was
cheesing over that episode for at least
two to three days afterwards it was so
dope my boys from Buffalo are posting
that
one that was a special one it was so
sick W what a cool ass dude him and his
uh cousin Jimmy actually like we said we
met up with them couple days later
dropped off some weed cuz they were
leaving town
and then they're like you trying to
smoke and in my head I'm like yeah I'm
trying to smoke been bumping your album
for nine months like straight like yeah
I'm trying to smoke and then we're
standing there he's like hey man we
should do a 420 event together oh run it
so we're going to figure all that out so
hopefully Griselda Do's usual something
me and OG vers uh Benny uh Conway and
Westy gun basketball
uhhuh I don't know if you're good at
basketball that's the thing you're good
at basketball I'll shake somebody
[__] 30 years ago I'll shake somebody
and pass it to you uh-huh and then I
yeah we just feed o will be there just
shooting the ball I bet OG's got a good
little back down hook shot I he probably
does he probably does you've never seen
him play basketball no he always does
this you've seen him shoot no he does
this in his garage oh when he when he
over us to over tax people on packs as
soon as they walk out the door he go
like that all right got him every you
see OG doing that it means he just got
off the phone and he he got over
some some and not even like in a bad way
it's like when he used to sell packs by
20 sell for 22 this guy sell for 27
let's see if I can get it off and he'd
leave all right who'd you get
[__] oh that's when I knew he
got somebody like but I'm like you've
done that to me you piece of [__] uhuh
and then we found out the whole sell me
a shitty pound story a couple years ago
[__] OG um yo it's been a minute I
really just want to like Marty power
smoke a joint right
now okay here we go here we go so that's
that's what's been going on guys we've
been playing catchup uhhuh we've been
having mad guests also which told you
yesterday so weird will sassa text me
yesterday we're like becoming friends
with the guest will sass is awesome we
sent him a bunch of stuff uh when he's
on he's going on tour he's hitting up
he's just it's just weird it's always so
weird where you ever get on Tik Tok goes
in your content tax May mhm that's right
huh that's right Tony Hawk cont I always
forget man um shout out to Mercedes
today today the first time anybody's
ever done that to me we walked up he
goes aren't you the dude from dope as
usual podcast he didn't say aren't you
do he said aren't you the guy from do
usual podcast oh [__] he's only seen one
episode is the ad one he all since then
I've been
watching so like all right different
different fan basee they never even
heard of our we [__] first that's
awesome that's what we want to hear it's
pretty cool um so let me just recap real
quick real quick so followed by the hex
episode so oh my God followed by the hex
episode and then this one we were
supposed to have another guest episode
today go flood his page flight reacts
did not show up today go flood his page
OG's doing a weed event with him
tomorrow all right OG has a weed event
with him tomorrow and I told him when he
gets there you tell oh man what's up man
what happened it's okay it's okay but
yeah flight reacts uh supposed to be
here today didn't so perfect timing for
a solo episode no no like oh damn I want
him on the show but God I want to talk
[__] for two hours too it's been a it's
been a while since I've got to talk [__]
at the camera
mhm I'm just kidding yeah these these
cameras don't know yet they don't know
fck new guys you have to have resin all
over
them oh man power smoking joints give
that' be funny if we went to resell our
old cameras and there was just like I
find just a layer of like reclam [__]
res my sister went to college I I I gave
her my Honda to my dad and she found
push tree stickers and sticky dabbers
underneath the floor floorboards oh [__]
she's like I just clean in the car I
know we go to school she like I found
all this do you want I go uh nah you can
throw it in the trash
sorry [__] dabs stuck under the
carpet
how the Dabber went through the side
around and down God or I filled my trunk
up so many times that it went through a
crack I used to do a lot of drop offs in
that car so I get it
um real quick guys I got to break it
down for you little story time all
right I went out of the country I'm a
birthday Rosie and John and and and uh
Rachel everybody set up like a a a
vacation thing you guys know I don't
really care about vacations but I'll go
I don't like plans I'll go I don't like
water not getting in you guys know this
[__] went to the Bahamas right let's
just break it down for you real quick I
hate flying we got the the lay down
seats where you just coughing up and I
watch Princess Bride Nacho Libre and
Step Brothers and then when I before I
knew it I was in another country so
anyway I'm in the lay down seat and
right Marty and tell you as I'm pressing
all right don't freak out just lay
down I see this dude in the suit one the
first class lay down seats right next to
me piece of [__] first off he's just
sitting crossle with like loafers
reading a newspaper right off the bat
I'm I'm I'm boy I haven't seen a
newspaper thank you he's going to call
me boy or or SPI or something like I
could see it on his face like you are
wondering how I'm next to you I know
that's what you're wondering right now
like how the [__] is this supposed
sitting next to me in first class I like
the look on his face he might have been
the nicest man on the world but like the
appearance is
like I'm gonna avoid you cuz if you
you're mean to me I'm GNA knock you the
[__] out that's all am only talking to
old people they're racist I'm going be
an [__] but you knocked an old man
out you didn't hear what this
[__] said to me you I mean he
was thinking it so that's why I just
just avoid it anyway I know it's so sad
I'll get into it later I avoid people
because I'm afraid they're going to be a
dick here we go I'm
[Music]
laying down and I just stopped like are
you [__] kidding me the old man next
to me has a newspaper he's one next to
me and up one so I can see what he's
reading I'm putting it down it just
says plane crash Survivor talks about
this like what the [__] and it's just
talking about plane crash he's reading a
specific newspaper with two articles
about plane crashes and the guy's
talking about how bad it was and but he
survived as I'm going oh [__] man we
just we're barely looking in the air and
I was like man this some [__] give
me a juice and I got a juice and that
was pretty much the end of that and I
woke up well I was I was H in and out of
sleep na Libra was still like trying to
make food and then at the end he was
like driving the bus so I was like oh
[__] I'm in out of sleep um real quick
not Libra that's a real story I'm just
throw it out there were we just talking
about nacho Libra oh we just talking
about the yeah so we get there guys
everything cool I'm going to say this
now if you're from the Bahamas I I
apologize first off we have fans of the
Bahamas which is very cool shout out to
you guys I don't remember your names I'm
sorry I was drunk continue so when you
think of the word Bahamas you think of
basically Paradise I only think of
Michael Scott doing the things in his
beard beads in his hair coming back from
s Jamaica and all I think about is like
Wow you went to the islands was it fun
I'm GNA say this now I'm not talking
about everybody went to a certain Resort
you guys know I don't say nothing to
nobody I don't talking to nobody I went
out of my way to say good morning have a
good day to 40 different people Marty
how many think how many people do you
think said hi to me back or acknowledge
I was a person judging by your tone very
few like
nine it wasn't helping me like I don't
even like talking to people I said good
morning [__] you're not going to say a
[__] word to me oh you're not helping
this you're making me go that's why I
don't talk to [__] you know what I
mean
was it a language thing they speak
English it's an English speaking country
first oh okay yeah the British went and
stole that [__] that's where they landed
that's right right yeah yeah so that's
the real America down there it's the
real
America so I mean there was a cashier I
was like hello have a good day and did
this to
me maybe maybe they have like different
body language in their culture she
didn't even say a word back to me did
she feel she was the [__] on the resort
I had to go there every day she worked
there every day every day she didn't say
hello back or acknowledge that I existed
or nothing oh anyway get over that
smoking chilling cool all that [__] got
a mopeds and you drive on the left side
there never drove a moped never drove on
the left side not
fun the RO they let you just get in and
go bro what I have a
license I'm going for 45 on the street
that's confusing it was scary going left
and there's a lot of
roundabouts so I was like uh where do I
get a [__] and I'm with John and them
not obeying the traffic laws so they're
leading me so I'm like am I doing the
right thing or am I like disobey like
are you trying to like keep up with them
type of [__] yeah oh God I was trying to
keep up with them dude and they have no
what were you guys driving
mopeds okay driving ATV fast you can go
like 60 Jesus Christ okay so we go to
this fish fry place that I can't eat at
anyway so cool we go there people are
super nice it's dope but I'm looking
around
like all you FS got watches on and
[__] did it feel safe or did it like it
was cool it was cool here we go okay got
to night time when Rosie wasn't with me
it was like a couple of us went out it
was night time and we're right smashing
just going around this town we go around
downtown stop like there's a live music
thing they like let's stop and check it
out like I don't give a [__] but okay
we're about to go there and then there's
that fight the uh Izzy fight was on so
we're going to go to the casino and go
watch
it I'm pulling off taking like a short
turn like a quick turn and I forgot I
didn't put my helmet on so I stopped to
put my helmet on right when I stopped
two like dudes that live there whatever
goes hey you're riding late I'm like is
it that late goes you're riding late out
here it was like 11: nobody else is out
the street but us and he said it
like go home that's how he said like get
the [__] out of here what did it look
like was it like Third World style or
was it just regular no no it wasn't like
Third World style it's like
uh it's just a town but 90% of the
buildings were for lease okay did you
was there a bunch of sketchy people
lurking around it's not that there was
sketchy people luring it it was and want
say this everybody's super courteous in
driving they could tell we didn't know
what the [__] we're doing everybody
stopped we just do this let us run
through Reds just
going hella polite everybody's such a
polite driver there so super duper
obvious you guys are Americans bro come
on they're looking at us like they're
going to get hit by a [__] car let
them go and remember I'm on the left
side taking a right on this highway I'm
like how do I all right look back look
straight all right take a right but do
you have the RightWay mhm because you're
taking a left so the left is the
RightWay here not the right is the
RightWay and I was just sitting there
like you go you go and I'll go like
seven times they should we should have
got by cars they should give you some
instructions before they give you the
moped anyway um remember guys there
about six of us John's going 65 in a
[__] four-wheeler flying flying
everybody else flying I'm the only thing
I'm thinking is if I fall off and hit my
[__] face what we can't do the show
for how long I'm good so I'm cruising at
40 40 like
this it's a little moped dude I can pick
it up with me on it it's like are you on
concrete or like uh on the gravel road I
mean I'm on the the asphalt it's just a
street okay yeah and every time I see a
speed bump I hold on for dear [__]
life cuz it goes one time I hit bounced
scared the [__] out of me anyway I'm the
sixth person back I'm cruising remember
a lot of oneway streets and you drive on
the left so I was like I'm going get on
the right side it's a oneway street I
feel normal here and then some little
car pulls up next to me remember I'm the
last person John's three four blocks
ahead can't hear me if I yelled and I
was like
yo PR sketch you back here and I had
that damn diamond necklace that I just
got like I'm not going to I shouldn't
have wore this it was a
present I was like damn dude okay I'm
driving we're heading back to the casino
and they're [__]
flying there was one point where me and
John's brother got lost for 10 minutes
couldn't find anybody we just found them
at of McDonald's it's at 11 o'clock at I
just dusted us is there cops yeah
they're on mopeds I mean they're on a
Segways what the [__] that crazy tall
Segways like one wheels and traffic and
Sh dude on the sidewalks it was trip
there was a couple trucks but like while
we got in there like cops on
Segways okay continue there's fools
climbing trees and throwing coconuts
down some on the side of the road and
there's [__] Segways out here you
guys are advanced in the wrong way here
we go cool country though like people
that were nice were [__] nice mhm
I'll say that much people that were nice
were nice maybe the people at the hotel
were just annoyed I they were annoyed
with Americans I know because we went
out everybody was [__] nice as [__]
to us not one person was rude was there
a lot of Americans around no the last
day we were leaving to the airport I
know it's hell American fools sorry
continue I'm riding my
moped trying to keep up and you know
everybody drives on the right side of
the car they don't drive on the left
side of the car the steering wheel's on
the right side like England and you
drive on the left side of the road just
like England right
okay so I'm
driving and I you know when you look to
the car next to you and rular the
traffic and like you can see the
passenger and then it goes through and
then the person's driving the fool's
right [__] next to you so I'm like
elbow to Elbow I'm like oh [__] there's
a guy with his elbow out his car like
right next to me you don't think I've
never been on a motorcycle I don't think
about those things I've never been that
close flying that fast I'm like I can
smack you right in the [__] chest if
I want right so I'm like and I see him
pop up and I'm like all right man why
you so close to me and I look and he
goes hey I'm like what's up man I'm
going like 40 he goes want to buy some
cocaine and I'm like n I'm good man
thank you though man I went thank you
though dude and I kept going goes hey
I'm like [__] this while you're moving
while I'm going 40 in tra like just
flying down the streets he comes up next
to me hey do you want to buy some
cocaine he said it
like this is my [__] house he said it
like do you want to buy some cocaine
very nicely but like uh you want to buy
you want to buy some cocaine that's
exactly how he said it to me I'm like no
I'm good though thanks though man that's
why I went thanks though man to make him
like oh he's just some [__] tourist
and then I'm going 2 seconds later hey
hey
what about
marijuana and I'm like no man I didn't
want to go I got a shitload of weed I
didn't want him to be like oh so you got
weed on you huh uhhuh I didn't want that
so what I did was like no I'm good man
and I swear to God for everyone if
everyone's driving and you got to watch
this part later I'm driving he's driving
the [__] does
this
Batman's into an alley does it look
looking at me marijuana no
okay goes down a [__] another Street
like he built the the city he didn't
even [__] look and just went all
right going 40 turns directly down the
street like a Grand Theft Auto game like
when they the old games go like
this and make direct 90° angles the
[__] Batman when he goes in
Michael Keaton off the building and he
DS down and disappears when the guy's
like I swear to God there was a bat
that's how I felt the [__] just
dipped off off camera off my site
hit the custy signal I swear to God he
did he went and left he didn't he was
looking at my eyes like no marijuana
okay and just turned
left damn he could hit a
wall he was looking right at me I was
looking at him man I don't know how he
did it so either he does that 30,000
times an hour or I can't do
that you what saying that slick like it
he didn't look and started doing the
turn
with you and [__] as you was turning and
then I went [__] this 60 until I got up
to everybody went hey don't [__]
leave me out there like dude what if
that fool just bump me and just rob me
like I would have no chance at all but
uh was it jungle or was it like normal
City oh you're C and the middle and in
the middle just hell palm trees coconut
trees oh I know yeah it was it was a lot
of grass area though a lot of
fields
I don't know how to describe it it's a
very odd you been to Hawaii
nope it's first time I ever went to the
to the place with water and [__] like
that besides John's wedding hold on
continue John and them know I don't go
swimming I don't go on the ocean I don't
give a [__] we got this gigantic boat
and I'm like how far in the ocean are we
going like dude we're going to be like
swimming distance from a [__] Island
I go oh not freaking out then we got out
there and I'm looking I'm like I can see
the the bottom of the ocean what the
[__] that means I see a shark coming I
ain't getting in that [__] still like
you want me to see my [__] demise no
doesn't make it any better and I'm the
only human that's not in the water at
this point even the babies are in the
water like but they're in like a
makeshift pool that has a net that you
sit in the ocean with that's cool so
we're sitting in there they have jet
skis going seabobs going I'm just like
I'm going to smoke a joint I have my
joint ready and I'm like ah we're
[__] 80 yards from the shore so R
goes off on the little Seabob Seabob is
a little thing you hold and you go you
can go underwater it's so [__] cool
and Rosie's like yo tone get Thomas so I
hop on the jet ski go to the Island the
island is 70 yards away it's just an
island with trees and a fence and then
in the ocean and I smoked a fat ass
joint donut I smoked it and I was just
looking at the ocean and I was like what
the [__] I'm smoking a joint on an
island never thought I'd even be close
enough to the water for that so I'm
sitting there smoking a joint I'm like
let me see that seab Bob I go one foot
in the water just enough to keep me a
like on the water so you're laying with
I'm laying flat and I just go and I take
off
15 hooked I'm like all right let me go 3
feet in the water and I go 3 feet in the
water and I look laugh and it's just
I've never been underwater I've never
been able to look underwater only in
video games I have that phobia of the
water do you have goggles on yes I have
that phobia of uh being in Open Water
like even if I see fools diving on TV
I'll just check like I'm going throw the
[__] up it's just like a fear of like
endlessness like I dick can't [__] with
it and I'm sitting there I'm like [__]
it I'll go 5et in it's right here
everybody's next to me [__] it I go down
I'm going like 15 and I dip and right
when I dip I go through a school of
fish and I'm looking left and right and
there's a school of fish swimming around
my body and I was like are you [__]
kidding me this is insane and they're
all transparent fish so you can see
through them almost and I was looking
around I looked down it's a big ass log
covered in
Coral like this is the ocean this is
[__] awesome and I came up and I was
[__] hooked was it easy to operate
yeah you just press it and move like
this and it drags your body and if you
want to dip you just look down and
you'll
go you want to go up you go it's [__]
it's like have I described it as in
Space Jam when Michael Jordan gets taken
into a hole that's how it is like you're
just hanging on to something so I go
like 10 ft out and I was like [__] it
let me go 10 ft out and I start swimming
in circles and I'm could not believe I
was in the ocean shocked me blew my mind
smoking The Joint sitting there smoking
The Joint I'm like oh my God this is
crazy I'm out there for like two and a
half hours just on the shore though I'm
I'm good and then I'm like you know what
I'll go back to the boat and I'll get
something that that's a good test it's
like 80 yards that's a good test
everybody's doing stuff there's other
boats there so I'm not like there's no
sharks right here this is the place they
bring the tourists because of that
reason
okay I get [__] 30 yards and just
froze I froze up I got 30 yards and it
went and then I curled my legs up and I
just held the button like this and it
just in a ball Dr brought me back I just
like held my feet and I just went like
this it looks so stupid you're supposed
to be laying out [__] and I'm in a
ball like this closing my [__] eyes
just looking at the shore like okay
[__]
nasty I hate the water anyway continue
Rosie went like 90 yards out I was
losing my mind the whole [__] time
this just so scared cuz I'm like if
something happens I got to go out there
okay a couple questions can you is there
a battery monitor on this [__] thing
or can it yeah you can there's a battery
life on the side you can see it it
lasted like 3 hours are your hands like
fastened in or you can it'll stop the
second you like go oh okay it's a
throttle you'll never get away from you
floats how deep can you go as deep as
you want
man [__] you're going 15 mph just
going you're you're [__] Aquaman
you're Poseidon so I've done jet skis on
lakes never on the ocean obviously so at
the end at the very end I'm like all
right I'll get on the jet
ski jet skis on the ocean is way
different I was going 60 on that [__]
and there was waves coming and I went
what happens if I hit a wave am I going
to start flipping no you just put your
weight into it cut right through it I
cut right through [__] big
waves it was wild man I stopped
completely turned the [__] as far as I
couldn't gasing was doing [__] donuts
and a [__] somebody filming all this I
don't know probably me and John were out
there we were [__] doing so circles
with each other causing like all these
crazy ass waves and then I just went as
fast as I possibly could hit like 65 and
then I got to the point where I was
flying back and I almost couldn't hang
on so I just I just
stopped and that was the ocean guys got
in the [__] ocean that's it nice got
in don't have no desire to do it more
unless it's stuff like that but [__] it
I finally got in the ocean guys never in
my life did I think I'd be in the
[__] ocean ever pass by Michael
Jordan's house he has a house right
there in the yeah you could just see it
from the water I remember seeing it cuz
someone's like that's Michael Jordan
like oh that is the Michael Jordan's
house cuz I saw a Tik to of him people
taking a cruise and he waved him when
he's on his [__] he was just smoking
a cigar on his back porch That's the
ocean wow I'm like oh [__] that is
Michael Jordan's house um if would you
want a place on there to like is could
you be like yeah lives here oh yeah yeah
he's he's billionaire mhm I don't like
planes if planes if you could just go
like yo it's triple but you can press a
button you just be there like like Willy
Wonka [__] you can [__] TV me over
there do it run it [__] this chocolate
bar take my [__] that little cowboy kid
was a little piece of [__] in Willy
Wonka [__] that kid
sorry what's up guys taking a moment to
talk about one of our sponsors and this
is my bookie whether it's UFC baseball
football or basketball make sure you're
betting with my bookie do us a favor
right now click the link in the
description no matter what platform
you're watching the link in the
description follow that bet $50 and
you're going to get $200 instantly
credit to your account bet 50 get 200
back even if you lose that 50 at least
you got the $200 credit listen to what
I'm saying guys it's a win-win win-win
situation also UFC 294 October 21st is
coming up go ahead and bet right there
Marty and I we're going to go spend some
money even if it's just fun to watch the
fights and hope you win you forget you
could possibly win a bunch of money too
that's one thing we didn't consider I
know it's betting but it's like it's
more fun than anything slot games live
casino table games there's much more
than just betting on sports but remember
if you're going to bet anything anywhere
anytime make sure it's with my bookie
once again click the link in the
description bet 50 bucks that first
deposit 50 bucks you automatically get
$200 credit to to your account once
again shout out to my bookie thank you
for
watching what's up guys taking a moment
from this long ass episode to talk about
one of our brand new sponsors you've
seen them in previous episodes this is
zodic and also that giant joint you
smoked with cheich that was also all the
zodic flavors so if you want to see the
store locator more information about
each drain yes they have each drain
broken down on their website go to Z AIX
420.com that's zodic 420.com
are you [__] [__] me [__] damn
looks beautiful I we dead stopped in my
track I had to really pause for a second
this is the OG diesel very cool bag this
[__] looks incredible hi Chris 420 or
Chris is the founder of zodic he
actually has his own YouTube channel you
can watch a bunch of informational
videos he's uh in the wholesale market
for over 20 years one of the first
wholesale distribution licenses so what
we're trying to say is thank you zodic
for sponsoring the show but also
crushing it doing a great job if you see
him at events go let them know you saw
him on the dope as usual podcast go
follow their inag stagram zicore
lifestyle thank you guys so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode so now you're out of
the ocean okay I'm on a lazy river doing
my thing on a lazy river in the thing
and I have my I have all my stuff my
phone my this my that cuz I I didn't go
to the room I didn't know there lazy re
I'm like [__] it like just don't fall
bro don't tip I make it all the way to
the end and the next thing I know I'm
pushing my [__] face off the bottom
of the Lazy River with my phone in my
hand and I come up lose my glasses in
the Lazy River one of my slides is gone
my phone's just soaked and I'm looking
up at the sky like yo this is the
[__] worst first
day and the iy found my glasses and my
shoe and then my phone worked still so
it was a great
day and I started walking around I met
some fans they were [__]
shocked like what the [__] bro came my
family didn't expect to see you like I'm
just killing I'm just chilling uh to
come of the workers were like you like
YouTuber guy I watch go oh yeah man like
is that you I'm like depends who are you
watching I like oh yeah that's me man I
never just go yeah that's me ever is it
normally are they asking if you're you
or are they just knowing you look just
like a YouTuber guy a lot of fols say
that like oh yeah what's that like is
that was that you all the time all the
time unless people know recognize my
shirt or something but yeah in the
Caribbean it was cool they were actually
fans which is pretty dope man somebody
that April grew up with wrote her on
Facebook and was like I was in a Uber in
Florida and mentioned I was from Buffalo
and the dude's like my favorite YouTuber
from Buffalo shut the [__] up yeah that
was the first time I actually heard
myself referred to as a YouTuber that
was [__] funny I mean I guess so
you're not a
spotifierr.com uhuh I guess you are a
YouTuber Marty that's so from rapper to
father to YouTuber
uhhuh but exactly while you were in the
Bahamas I did have a real nice meeting
with Spotify that's explicitly told them
what we need to do to start being able
to build the community on Spotify so
first of all shout out to them for all
the continued support shout out to them
for putting [__] Brown bagp on
Time Square boards official [__] uh I
the joint sorry all good sure just
realized right now and for taking our
feedback and asking how we could make
things better on Spotify and I told them
the way to make it so YouTube doesn't
have a monopoly on young long form video
is to let us have likes comments lives
premieres let us talk to the fans B the
community so if if Spotify adds comments
likes dislikes lives or premieres thank
this fool hopefully for real it would
really help out because they that's the
second year in a row we're like you know
what would be really helpful likes but
this time was different this was the
their whole programming team whole team
now they know Spotify knows that like oh
you guys are you guys are here I'm like
yeah we're we're not just saying you
know women don't do this and men don't
do that bit we're not doing that [__]
just so just I mean I'm not saying it's
bad there's more to it than that yeah
and the same week we did a [__]
interview with the New York
[__] times New York
Times
give me a check mark wait we bought it
never
mind I forgot I haven't said that in so
long I bought on my check marks they
like yo here you little [__] like
[__] just sell it to me well let you
pay us let me pay you that's pretty much
what we asked
them um this doesn't taste like the
lemon this is the
horchata one hor of joint M and mixed it
up in all of those and picked the only
[__] one that wasn't limited
I just saved it as a as a taste breaker
mhm [__] it all right here we
go we got the bills in London this
weekend in London yes games at goddamn 6
a.m. anyone from UK that watches please
tell us if you give a [__] about
football the oot not the
UB football f o o t oh not the original
football that we stole gotcha football
at Indians land and coming up this week
we're going to start getting in placing
some [__] bets oh we got some
bets going
um I fell off of football MH watching a
lot of UFC lately yes a lot oh it's my
first [__] cage fight oh yeah I
didn't even hear about that I didn't
even ask you about that we got [__]
fans the dudes that run it watch our
show and they gave me their number and
they said please come next time we'll
give you a table remember I told you
yeah kickbox fight we're we're going to
go sorry tell you about that there are
fans which is [__] awesome like the D
came play hey man your like thanks thank
you um okay let me say something
else I was at the fight and the story
time when my my dealer John P uh
disappeared remember I said I owed him
20 bands and the last thing I ever did
was meet his girl at a taco shop and
gave it to her and she said she just
still know where he was oh
[__] so I'm sitting there at the fight
I'm in the [__] front row and over
the cage is like the fighters chill
homies and people doing work or I look
at this girl I'm
like is that you I'm like I know faces
I'm [__] good at this and she looked
at me like I looked away I'm like what
what the [__] is that I don't want to
say her name but like is that
you and it kind of felt like I was I
being a purv cuz I kept looking at her
but I'm looking at every crease of her
face like I remember that how long you
didn't know that 12 years ago so I don't
know that I don't know that in your
face that's you I know it and OG told me
later he like that girl just was just
taking a picture of you I'm like for
real she like she zoomed in took a
picture of me I was like that's her
that's that's got to be her her dude it
has to be but I'm thinking like I'm not
trying to be a [__] weirdo but she
was taking a picture of the fight and
I'm so obsessed right now at the fight
like is that you where is like where is
John like where is he he's still missing
would you not go up and talk to her I
didn't want to make it weird in Cas cuz
she didn't she didn't she made a point
to not like make eye contact yeah yeah
yeah right this is what [__] me up are
you ready he's been gone for about 12
years I fully believe she knows where
he's at and he's just on the
[Music]
Run [__] bleep that all right I think
he's just disappeared because he's
almost said it again because he's in
trouble God Jesus
Christ cuz he's in trouble that would so
[Laughter]
stupid
anyway I'm like he's on the run because
when I saw her you don't know where he's
at she's like I haven't heard from him
and the way she said I was like [__]
you know way more than you're saying but
his mom is crying putting up ads please
let her know that he's not dead oh like
you should say some [__] like not me I'm
his homie at least let his brothers know
they're putting him missing person signs
like this is not cool is he the type of
person that would put would like allow
that to go on to them he don't know that
he's gone I mean what would he would he
just assume that they would think he's
dead I don't
know but I guess it might be the most
Clos yeah that's what I'm saying I mean
that we've talked about it but the
people that were looking for him like
were constantly calling his moms
constantly calling a homie Ryan
constantly calling Wingstop where Ryan
was a manager trying to [__] find him
calling his little brother's job daily
yeah they don't know where he's at
they're calling Wing Stop for [__]
information they're not you don't know
where he's at you
know so anyway sorry I'm sitting there
and I notice she's taking and like I
said I felt like a creep cuz I kept
looking at her I kept looking at
her and she's taking a
picture of the cage and whether or not
I'm right or wrong it's just something I
thought of took a picture and closed it
off and when she closed it off there was
a picture of like a 10-year-old blonde
kid on her phone
my homie is a blond hair blue-eye
guy okay it's like is that a picture of
your [__] baby on your phone is that
a picture of your son that you is that
your kid is that my homie's kid where is
he that's all I kept thinking like
there's a blonde boy on your [__]
phone you Mexican chick you know what
I'm saying I'm like that's her I know
it's her she's sitting right there the
whole night won't just doesn't even look
that one night I'm sitting there going
how big is this venue is this like a
Prett big okay Casino fight a fight
thing but she's right next to us like
right there but I see her taking the
picture I'm just like obsessing over
like is that you I don't want to make it
weird cuz she's had a boyfriend with her
hey I knew your old boyfriend is that
you that's not his kid like I didn't
know what to do I didn't want to go you
guys friends I knew her me and her
boyfriend you and her were you friends
uh yes all right yeah I would say that
but you haven't seen her on Instagram or
anything since then oh no no no no she's
not she's just not an Instagram person
her brothers hated John they're all
gangbangers they used to shoot at each
other all that [__] remember I told you
I if I still on here but anyway gang
making ass Brothers um hat the boyfriend
oh [__] despised him oh [__]
yeah
and and uh oh there's there's a shitload
of joints right here I don't know why
the [__] we're sitting here sharing a
roach oh my God we have fat ass joints
right here
yeah we got weed for days Exotics there
a box of weed from Exotics thank you
guys
um so that threw blew my mind when I was
there's a blonde boy on your phone like
a school picture like that's your kid
you don't just have like a homie's kid
on your phone is her new boyfriend
Mexican or Mexican as
[__] okay so I'm like that's not his kid
MH I know it was her I didn't bring it
up I asked Rosie right before we left
like hey if you see her can you just ask
ask her if that's what's her name is
what her name is and if it is just look
at me and I'm going to walk over
there but waiting to see her after can I
got kind of got commotion I start taking
pictures of some fans and
[__] bro it [__] me up I'm sitting
there watching the fight and doing
this thinking of all the things like I
hope that fool's alive I wonder what
he's doing is that you like and like and
the kid on the phone like I kept
thinking of all these things like is
this real you know what I mean like when
you wake up from a dream going is that
[__] oh I was dreaming cuz I've never
been to a fight what are the odds it's
so what are the odds and then the thing
that got me was no Tony told me he's
like hey I saw that girl just taking
pictures of you like what do you mean
he's like I saw her doing this when I
was walking back and she was snapping
pictures of your
face oh God she was probably sending it
to her brothers like yo is this Thomas
uhhuh or I mean if homeboy is still
alive or to him were you guys like
really great friends yes would he try to
contact you or no no he's not contacting
his mom bro yeah or his bull
Brothers you know what I'm saying yeah
I'm going to say it now it's a
comeback it's not that much
money
now you know back then it was now it's
like let's work for a few months to have
your life back type of [__] have your
life
back wow I don't know I don't know I
don't know what to think it's just it's
just I I don't know I was thinking about
him the other day then I saw all that I
was like what the [__] was he like a
regular dude or was he like wild gang
banger type of dude no he's a white
blonde hair blueeye drug
dealer super cool super awesome like
funny [__] just awesome as [__] just
like drugs a lot like pills way too much
and the reason he got in with the gang
bangers is cu he was supplying all these
fools with packs all the time CU they
were his girlfriend's bu brothers and
they were gang danging ass
fools I know one of them he's [__]
awesome
but he'll shoot you
um and what happened they kept getting
into it he got in with some Northerners
he got into with some other Northerners
and then some then he was chilling with
the southerners and [__] probably
shouldn't go too into everything but my
homie was down as [__] like he's not a
gang banger but I was like it's a lot of
that one color you're wearing today
huh [__] I know where you're going yeah
what's that he's chill with a lot of
Asian gang banger fools so he wor you
might not be a hooker but you're wearing
the uniform you're wearing the uniform I
may look like an officer just because I
dress this
way yeah um he chilled a lot of Asian
mod gay Banger blue [__] fulls so he was
very affiliated with everybody but he
was man he was cool man he was cool as
[__] dude and uh how old was he when
this all happened when he was gone he
was
24 two years older than me mhm I was 22
and he was gone and there was a bunch of
[__] going on when he disappeared
or I knew because I was was the one
making sure he was
[Music]
alive but was he on like as in like no
what happened is he he was getting 100
packs boxes but 100 packs at 3,000 a
piece that's 300 bands be
careful and he was just two and too many
Oxys and he would lose track of time
lose track of money lose track of there
was so many times I give him 10 man like
what like for the pounds dude I'm only
saying 10 is a flat number cuz it was
never just
10 yeah give me the one that's 1,200 and
the one that's 1,800 yeah right fool
it's [__] 39 or it's 34 it's [__]
I was just saying even numbers to be
even numbers there's never been 10 bands
I've ever bought any drugs for and uh
there'd be times you be like oh yeah
yeah yeah I'm like you got no idea I
could asked you to front me 30 and you
would had no idea I got them from you
and you know I I've talked about it
before I'd walk in he'd be passed out
like doors open 200 band's worth of weed
just sitting on the [__]
door it's careless what happens he
[__] careless got
selfish how much space does 200 bands
worth of weed occupied that like right
there knee level got at 3,000 a PB yeah
okay you know what I mean yeah yeah yeah
it's [__] 100 pound 120 lbs at most
mhm not
much um he was only making [__] three
three points 300 bucks on a pound it's
not like he was going hard but he was
doing 300 lb sometimes at a day cuz he's
he's he's dropping them off like you
want a 10 pack you want a 20 you want a
20 I'll put three bucks on each quot me
three three bands break them down he's
going to make three bands a pack yeah
gotcha or he can just like here's a box
gone here's another 100 bound here's
another 20 gone here's another 20 G
here's another 20 gone my rent is 1,200
yeah I madean 1,29 minutes
mhm you see how how how it works out
that way yeah um your
joint is it is like is it hard to find
uh people to buy in that volume like
that it's got to be right yeah unless
you want to deal with [__] fools you
don't want to deal with yeah
yeah um I don't know how we got to Sol a
topic oh the fight cage fight was
sick I never seen nobody get I never
seen leg kicks in person o you can hear
them like Twigs breaking it's like a bat
it's like a bat
hitting a leg a leg Yeah I was trying to
think what's soft that would like a pig
leg a human leg you [__] idiot you
know man no I'm good oh my God no thanks
I saw a guy here we go I saw a guy come
up physical peak condition Peak human
Peak human 12th
fight saw his opponent and I went sir
where do you keep Zelda where's the
Zelda at in this GameStop that's what
the [__] you should be asking the
opponent the man was 35 years old first
fight 61 200 100 lb with no muscle on
his body wait and he just and he was his
first fight he was fighting the Peak
Physical human man that's scary it
wasn't fair
bro so he's like a dad who's been like
doing Jiu-Jitsu type he's definitely not
a dad okay he's one of those dudes just
works at GameStop doesn't have a
girlfriend just chills which is totally
cool those guys aren't cage fighters
this guy was like yo I beat the [__] out
of a guy at a grocery store trying to
steal I think I could fight you know
what I mean like no bro beating up a
[__] tweaker homeless man versus
beating up 19-year-old Justin is
different the fight was a minute and 40
seconds no 155 and you ever seen
Christmas Story you ever seen when
Ralphie loses his [__] on him that's
exactly what the [__] happened art
farcus got the [__] beat out of him the
guy was long red hair oh nice by the
time he stood up his nose was broken
split both I almost shut oh God the
guy's never fought less than 2 minutes
and there was a gap in his
nose is there a worse [__] job to
have oh as I'm watching these guys fight
I go don't ever want to do this I don't
ever want to do this cuz there's one guy
in there that was throwing question
question Mar kicks kicks and he was
throwing and he question mark kicked the
guy in the cheek and I
saw spit and sweat like Rocky cuz it was
the back lit from the light I saw the
sweat go and I went never in my life do
am I this tough I well maybe I am I
don't want it I don't I can't wrap my
mind around how their pain tolerance is
so high I'm waiting for the day you see
one of these Fighters just [__] burst
out in tears midf fight just cuz [__]
[__] hurts so bad Bob St cried in the
ring did he you know Bob stap yeah he
cried uh when uh uh I said Ivan
Drago when Marco crocop broke his
[__] eye socket M he punched him in
the eye and broke his orbital bone Bob
sap cried in the [__] ring the guy
Bob sap is the guy that cries in The
Longest Yard you broke my nose the big
guy that picks up the bench he's a
[__] fighter destroying
Asia then Marco crocop comes and breaks
his [__] face in in one
CH crushed his over the B full hits the
ground and starts
sobbing yeah his face broke but he cried
like in the movie and I was like
wow you're good actor just like you did
in the movie I feel bad for him dude get
your orbital Bon smashed oh man that's
my face broke my face oh he that he lost
as he got hit he was over bro and then
for most Fighters yeah you're walking
away with barely like any money your
reputation everybody in your personal
life you've been like hyping up yeah but
dude saw the guy from GameStop just get
whooped what' he do to him like oh he
just beat dog [__] out of him slammed
him on his [__] head the guy covered
up as long as he could but he just
started getting the one arm on the he's
holding him down so the guy's on top of
him one arm on the hand and just hooking
his [__] nose to the left just
smashing him and I'm sitting there going
I kind of don't like watching this me
and Rosie at the end went did you feel
bad I felt bad every [__] fight every
fight as I'm watching the guy go oh I'm
going to get my ass whooped you can see
it on their face that they know they're
done it's not cool it's [__] up
actually it made me feel like when I
fought people and I'm beating the [__]
I'm go oh I'm a bully now like
I somebody gets crucifixed and they get
their hands pinned down and then the
dude just starts unleashing I saw a guy
get an arm bar so violently tight I
thought his arm was going to break and I
looked away then he got out of it don't
know how the [__] he got out of it Marty
this bone looked like it was pushing
through like his arm was completely
locked out and he just did this
one your arm rled it back uh-huh with
his arm he clamped his arm on this wrist
and got himself out of it anyway watch
the fight
whoa well there was like six fights wow
so I saw F get Molly wed so hard he just
hit the ground and he just started he
just finished him off I never seen
anybody get hit like that were you close
enough to be getting like sweat dripped
on you and [__] from for sure that's the
irony of having like expensive seats at
the [__] fight there was a all the
all the the staff was there and that
we're the first rope but wow we need to
go to UFC Marty we really really need to
go to UFC and we're going to throw paper
airplanes at Joe Rogan go
hey Marty go oh Marty come down here be
our co-host Daniel Corman get out of
this this guy's gonna smoke joints with
me and that's exactly what's gonna
happen you know what's [__] up I've
been listening to Rogan and DC for so
long that I think like listening to them
commentate that I think like them and I
say the [__] that they say right before
they say it so when we're watching UFC
I'm commenting I'm commentating
basically what's about to happen just as
if like I say the it happens all the
time it's like a running joke at the
house cuz I'm just like programmed to
view the view it like they taught me how
to watch it
you know so it's like if you wouldn't
know better I almost sound like I know
what I'm talking about when I'm watching
UFC I almost
sound um but yeah the fight was great
still
98% sure that that was my homie's old
girlfriend and if that's the case the
kid on that phone is my homie friend my
homie's kid because it's the right age
it's the right age like on her lock
screen type [__] you saw took the
picture and then she turned on as she
was bringing it down like [__] blonde
kid blonde little blonde
kid same [__] hair same [__] color
sounds like a dream same [__] color
hair man I'm doing this to Rosie the
whole time are you [__] kidding me
she going I can't believe that like if
that's her this is
crazy I'll see her next time the ring
guy that was her boyfriend the guy on
the side she'll be there again and I'm
gon to ask oh [__] for sure I can't let
it go twice the whole time I'm like what
am I doing what's he going to do how's
this going to help anybody except [__]
her up you know she ain't do nothing
wrong but you know what I'm saying yeah
I just I don't know how to feel the
exact right is so how did uh the dude
that you know do
fighting oh I never met any of the
fighters Rosy's boxing coach uh he
trains two of the fighters that's why we
went oh I thought he was fighting gotcha
no no no no I didn't know anybody that
was
fighting
but it was dope it was like Commerce
Casino there's a casino here in La we
went it was a casino a [__] ring it
was pretty sick like going to Vegas but
like just here MH not really like Vegas
but it was tight there was people
gambling anyway sorry continue what else
has been going on since then here we go
let's get into this let's get into this
guys how long are we at an hour clean
[__] all right so you guys ready for
this
one I was about 19 I thought I was just
a little [__] Story Time my pain
tolerance is that of children I can't
take finger pokes when I go to the
doctor I avoided going to the doctor for
seven years so I didn't have to get a
needle I have a phobia of needles just I
don't like being
stabbed I don't like things being
inserted into my skin and body no not
for me so my whole life it makes me gag
like oh my God there's a [__] piece
of metal inside me it's injecting [__]
take it out
anyway I might take so that that right
but you know hitting fools in football
getting Stingers crushing my [__]
[__] having the couchs fall on me
during [__] moving stuff fools
crushing foot you know wrestling and
slaming my [__] head skateboarding
all that [__] I'm like ow who cares it
hurts yeah it hurts but needles oh give
me paper cut I'm going to lose my
[__] mind can I [__] you up real
quick go yesterday April came home I was
mortified it looked like she got
attacked by a goddamn German Shepherd or
some [__] she got a micro needling
treatment done where at some [__]
place where like on her
face I've seen that [__] the blood the
blood thing
yes yes she like hell raising oh my God
yeah it was horrifying I was like didn't
hurt though no no it looked like she got
attacked by like a pack of leeches type
of [__]
it was three days or phas will be new
though yeah it went away right away but
that's that's the ultimate uh needle
[__] where I don't even know what that
in I got acupuncture the other day tell
god I didn't even tell you oh hold on
sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry I've seen somebody with the
blood face facial thing it's
disgusting right little straight [__]
when it comes to pain I
think here we go
so my back sucks I say that a lot my
back hurts back hurts the first time I
was 19 I was putting my shoe on to go to
work at me and EDS and I stood up and
went and I fell and the first thing I
thought was Hank Hill the episode where
he has whole herbal back pain when I was
a kid I saw go people have back pain
well I'm not going to be like that when
I'm old first thing I thought was like
oh I a kill couldn't put my [__] shoe
on I had to call off work for the first
time in my life life back went out never
felt that right back h i was 19
throughout the years my back hurts back
hurts there's be times where like I'm
walking around and I have to tie a shirt
around my waist so [__] tight so it
holds pressure on my hip because it
feels like something's pushing out of my
hip but when I go like this you ever Se
Me In videos do this I just like press
on my hip it's because something feels
like it's popping out so that's my way
of like trying to fix it uh helping Omar
move my back went out I tied something
around my waist perfectly fine second I
take it off I can't even walk it's like
so it's like a someone adds 5 Ines to my
right hip and I I'm stuck on one side
and I can't I can't move my hips back
anyway back hurts uh right before we
moved to Merced neck hurts but that's
when I started doing Instagram I was
doing thousands of comments a day I was
doing every single comment on YouTube
every single thing I was on my phone for
16 hours a day like this so my neck
would start to get stiff and it really
started to hurt right I was doing the
moving still how many times I said said
I pick up a damn couch and use my neck
as the leverage and hold the couch like
this because you can't really do it over
your head cuz it hurts Stick it to the
side of your neck you can hold a whole
couch on your shoulder fulls s
bullshitting so
continue my neck hurts went to the
doctor and this is the story about the
doctor that said uh oh you smoke
marijuana oh how do you even know how
your neck feels if you're always high I
can't treat you if you smoke weed that
doctor that story time where I talked
about it it was Rosy's family doctor I
called her stupid [__] in the most
polite way anyway not my doctor anymore
she was like your neck's fine I'm not
giving you an x-ray how do you know
you're smoking weed you don't even know
what you feel like sh you don't even
know what you feel like is what she told
me I know my neck hurts so I started
going to the to the um chiropractor SL
deep tissue massuse right sorry long
story even she was like something's
wrong with your neck you got like uh
something going on with your shoulder
blah blah blah anyway she would rub she
did my neck rubbed it out this huge
knots got rid of him came to La neck
still hurting you know I deal with it I
have to do those comments I have to do
comments I have to talk back to people
so I started doing this one like put my
head back and commenting like this I do
a lot of comments when I get in the
shower in the morning so the hot water's
on my back my bag isn't cramp
up yeah [__] you for everyone say I
don't give a [__] about these comments I
really do that [__] anyway back hurts
back goes out twice a year where I can't
walk for a couple days or I don't want
to walk cuz it hurts so bad happens
with's the story remember when we first
start of the podcast my Dad's here my
back went out me my dad chilled for a
week and a half blah blah all that [__]
right in August my back went out again
happens twice a year just about same
time back went out again I couldn't get
up my stairs like the second I put
pressure on my right hip I swear to God
it's like someone was just yanking a
knife out of my back like I know what
pain I feel pain but like yo what the
[__] that's like structural pain like I
can't move my hip so I had to put all my
weight on Rosie and she helped me up I
hopped up the
stairs and then what was it like 12 days
I was out right mhm I laid in bed for 5
and a half days straight didn't move tub
to bed tub to bed could not move found a
chiropractor full did [__] nothing
for me found a disc specialist a spine
specialist right so here we go guys I'm
going get into this little story I've
been going to the spine specialist since
about a week before the last solo
episode mhm so I've been going the spine
spine all right it's called spin Anatomy
the reason I'm even talking about it
spin atomy went and got my x-rays done I
mean x-rays my MRI is done you guys
ready for this my back hurts my back
hurts I every time we get out of this
chair go oh [__] sometimes I laugh in
videos go oh [__] cuz I'm trying not to
let it hurt my brain CU it hurts so bad
that sometimes I'll be sweating in video
because I'm just trying to hold it in
not because I'm hot most of the time
because I'm like
you know when fools get like sweats from
breaking a leg that's what I feel like
sometimes I'm like all right my back
seasoned right now like like right now
my left side's kind of seasoned up we
got to get new chairs but like it's
season up it hurts who cares right I'm a
little [__] I can't tolerate pain I go
get my MRIs cuz I walk in like your pain
level's what I go nine like all right so
this the worst like it [__] hurts
yesterday was a 10 we need to do
something got my MRIs on my lumbar got
my MRIs on my cervical and my th
thoracic that's your whole
spine that was not
wrong I wasn't wrong all the time they
say yo my back feels like it's [__]
breaking I can't most of the time like I
can't sleep because I can't lay on my
back cuz cuz my my back hurts but I can
get on my hip and once I get on my hip
my back stops hurting but then my hips
get shifted off but I can't lay my
stomach because it seizes my lower back
sometime I would just sit but I can't
sit for too long cuz cuz my lower back
gets seized
up hammock hammock or bat style the only
way I can really sleep
right went to the doctor and they're
like yo you look like you're in Pam like
I'm [__] sweating right now I was
pouring sweat guys trying to hold in the
and most of the time I'm like this
trying to keep the weight off of my hips
so I'm holding myself up in my chair at
home like this half the
time it's the worst [__] thing dude
back pain sucks didn't realize how bad
my back was ready all right guys this is
what's going on with my back I haven't
seen you guys in a while here we go we
got all my [__] back there is 25 discs
in your back I have 15 herniated disc 15
bulging discs 15 out of 25 of my discs
are not in place makes [__] sense of
why my back hurts so fad I mean there's
times it hurts so [__] bad that I'm
like I see why people shoot themselves
from from being in like chronic pain I
can totally understand why totally like
solo is like if I had a gun I would have
popped how many we do this like I I I
thought about shooting myself like I
don't know if I could do
this I'm not going to do that but
there's times where I'm like oh I get it
I [__] get why people people [__]
say that [__] like it's it's so bad that
you can't stand sit or lay what the [__]
are you supposed to do there's nothing
in the world you could do sometimes I
put my chest on my counter cuz it kind
of takes the weight off my hips and I
just kind of sit there how do I do [__]
sitting chest down I'm disabled at that
point anyway so stupid [__] doctor
frommer said this one's fractured my C3
is fractured and she's like it's an
older fracture I go oh I know where
that's from stupid [__] [__] told
that [__] doctor my neck hurt I knew
it hurt it hurt so bad I couldn't lift
my [__]
arm it's not like oh it h oh it's bad
it's like no it just won't it won't move
it feels like this shake it off like
this now put your chin your to your
chest I can't something's stuck my disc
is not in the place to move it's like
having your chain on your bike crumpled
it's like how are you supposed to ride
the [__] bike you don't it's get
stuck and that's impossible to
move 15 guys so the doctor looked at me
and goes hey a couple of your discs are
at 5 millimet 6 to 7 is when I would I
would suggest surgery like you need to
start fusing that I like what he goes
that's usually when people can't handle
it anymore and you have to get surgery
I'm like I'm not getting no [__]
surgery man he goes you are months away
maybe two years at most from getting
[__] surgery on those discs I'm like
you [__] kidding me he goes if you
don't take care of this I give it less
than 10 you're in a wheelchair for most
of the
day the [__] I feel I don't feel like
that and then I think about it like most
people don't have back pain severely all
day something's
wrong so that's why I was like all right
are you serious okay I'm going to get
I'm going to start on this I've been
doing decompression not the things the
inversion tables where you hang by your
ankles that's not what I'm talking about
I've been doing
decompression treatments stem cell soft
softwave treatments TENS unit and this
infrared laser thing I've go five times
a week it's become a job I'm there for
two hours of [__] day at
least anyway guys are you ready I've
been doing this [__] I've been doing
shout out to Dr Ryan from spine anomy
this is the reason I'm saying this I'm
getting better like my back is getting
[__] better two days ago I woke up
bent down grabbed something walked to
the bathroom went Rosie and I [__]
woke her up when I just bent over and
kept walking without having to hold my
breath without having to hold something
in place and it didn't hurt I haven't
done that since I was like 23 it's been
damn near over 10 years since I've been
able to to bend over without it hurting
and the thing a lot of people like fool
you're too [__] fat [__] I
was not too fat at 20 at 20 I was in
shape my back is terrible and now I
realize all those trying to go ego
lifting with a [__] fridge on my
shoulder trying to pick up the fridge on
my chest [__] on my cousins just
showing them up in all actuality was
crushing my
vertebrae every other one of them every
other one of them
do you guys get that like there's only
10 of my things in my spine that are
normal and uh my 12th session the other
day guys this is why I want to talk
about it I felt my spine pop back into
place one of them I felt one of my
vertebrae or my disc go back in a normal
spot Rosie was with me and she went what
was that I go you heard that I felt my
low I think it's called the L L5 I felt
it pop back into place isn't that in
isn't that crazy I I heard it but I felt
it and I described it as if you've ever
had an ingrown toenail and then right
when you get it out that relief but it
still hurts but then you feel the gap of
where that nail was cuz you have a hole
in your toe you know what I mean cuz it
was an ingr now you have that Gap I can
feel the Gap in my back it feels
like like I can
breathe it's the weirdest feeling ever
and you know what's crazy is uh two days
ago me and Rosie were sitting
and I had no not pain I had no feeling
in my back
like nothing was
bugging and that's when I realized like
oh this is what it's like to not be
hurting cuz I'm constant con it's just a
part of life I smoke weed like I know I
have back problems like oh yeah yeah
what's up oh no it hurts yeah sure oh
yeah I'm high I'm smoking another joid
though like oh no no no I'm I'm on fire
my back is I've tried to laugh it off
and I try not to let it show on camera
cuz you guys are not going to have fun
if you if you saw me when I'm hurting
you guys would not want to watch the
show no more I'm just sitting here just
squirming it [__] hurts man and uh so
yeah anyway this one's fractured four
out of seven on these ones are bulging
the middle I have seven bulging the
bottom I have five bulging five out of
five um but the worst one's 5 millim 6
to 7 mm of surgery so I'm dialing that
one back and then my other ones are
three and down so it's still I'm still
fixable but all I want to say is shout
out to [__] spy Anatomy because I
actually am starting to feel better
already I'm not even halfway done
through my procedures I have 15 more
still and I got 30 left on my neck like
I if this is working the way this is
working so
far I'm going to have a different life
yeah I don't like to go places my back
hurts I don't want to go I don't want to
sit there I don't want to stand there I
don't want to go to the store I don't
want to my back is on fire I don't want
to do that [__] the only time I forget
about it is when I'm on live or talking
because I forget when I'm talking to my
friend like talking talking they go get
up go oh oh [__] [__] [__] okay okay
let's go and it's
like quality of life is going to go oh
quality of life is going to go nuts dude
yeah just being able to think MH and not
just be like well your back is on fire
still like that sucks you took him out I
actually dumped
them uh why you've been going through
this April's been going through the
exact same thing Mar's wife it's
actually really sad what's worse is uh
one of her discs is three times worse
than one of mine yeah are you [__]
kidding me that no she needs to smoke
weed she needs to smoke [__] weed the
doctor even said how are you okay yeah
like you're you're okay and go I got to
deal with it it's like it's completely
debilitating it's kind of it's really
taking over our lives and it's ironic
that you two have the exact same thing
and are doing the exact same treatment
at the exact same time but I mean she
hasn't even been able to like here she's
barely been able to live these past year
or two she hasn't been able to like work
really or got this text
yesterday is that Josh oh [__] Josh on
the same table we're on oh nice you saw
me he's like hey look where I'm at he
has horrible issues well the idea with
it is that like you have like part of
your discs that's like hemorrhaging it's
like being pushed out in this um
decompression treatment is pulling it
back to like fix it back in place I
really hope it works it's going to work
it's going to work which is yeah crazy
cuz I never thought anything was going
to fix it dude it's like having a giant
thorn in your spine cuz she it's like
same thing for her she can never she
can't sleep she can't sit she can't walk
she can't do [__] she the thing is like
she's in shape I can't imagine if I was
in shape and my back was still well
imagine this it's she's she's got
multiple things going on because when
you have three kids you're ABS aren't
necessarily she had she just had surgery
to sew her ABS back together and then
what you do I'm going to go home and do
[__] the next day she kind of she
facetimed us yeah she ripped it she
thought she did she thought she did but
she like she it's the day after Ab
Surgery it was really actually gruesome
and scary cuz like the second night she
had so her abs are held together by like
this steel mesh but she started [__]
freaking out about two nights in the
middle of the night I mean imagine
waking up and like the meds have kind of
wore off you you now are are cut open
yeah with metal in you yes and you're
feeling that and realizing it it was
like made me just
[__] give me the HEBs just even
thinking about it so she doesn't have
any core strength you know like
literally you know what I mean like it
is [__] was so demeaning like she don't
got no course like [__] man it makes it
even worse on her back cuz her front's
chicken wire on her chest right she
needed to work on you know like getting
her core back it's it's a term it's
called diastasis women get it from
babies it rips your abs
apart uh but then as that's happening
this severity in her back started
happening you know she was in car
accidents and stuff when she was kid I'm
it's from but is that what Terell Owens
got no I was kidding remember how ter
Owens all buffed but his abs go like
left you remember that I thought a
million things when you said that is
that t Owens got no he's a man he can't
have babies sorry I always think when
people like I RI my ass like like there
Owens I than all that
all the before the N be warming up my
grandma's ner fan like why are his abs
turning you look it up look up TR
owens's
ABS how many children did he have dude
because bro TR owens's ABS they're like
taking a right turn yeah I guess so oh
no no no no he's all he's all strong man
now no when he was a skinnier dude you
could see it we should look at it I'll
find a picture cuz we me and my grandpy
should always say I don't know what the
hell happened all the time look like
deformed they're like this like the
state of California oh like a little
[__]
to but yeah so shout out to that doctor
shout out I mean I'm sure there's got to
be a lot of people out there going
through this type of [__] just live with
it cuz April was unaware of what was
going on forever you know like she
always had like you she just living with
the issues yeah then you go and get the
test and figure it out and you're like
oh [__] it's not even that it's like I
know if I was 100 PB lighter they'd be
like hey your back a lot less worse like
yep I figure she's in shape and to be in
shape and still go oh it's just my bones
yeah she that's [__] Wolverine
surgery
dude yeah animum what do you call it all
you nerds out there put in the chat
anthium we need a Mor for a new she
needs a new Avatar uh she need a new
Avatar you ever seen get out she's just
go to the South like uh I like that
blonde [__] give me that blonde [__]
like no no no she just got knocked out I
want a [__] that can
fight yeah
then she'll still arm wrestle
though I know I was there on your
birthday she started arm wrestling
random
people [__] oh yeah we went out we had a
good time with my birthday after episode
that's right we went after oh it was
right after the episode yeah Dam we
haven't been here in a minute that was
so long ago yeah it was everyone got
sick all the girls just start getting
sick no just like
clockwork oh you throwing up we were
standing there attention what happened
standing there like gz at attention it's
going all right yeah throw up for sure
sake that was so much fun thank you we
pulled up to the
restaurant opened up the [__]
oh the guy boxed the whole restaurant
they came out multiple time the lady
smell like [__] weed a regular
restaurant outdoor seating we went to
the crossroads of calab
and stunk it the [__] up we sat inside
yeah it was pretty bad so much that our
waiter said it like seven times about
how much we stunk he was fine with it he
was trying to get down with it he was I
think he was
um yeah it's been a minute and then we
did my birthday went to the
Bahamas that was cool obviously you know
we missed our connecting flight cuz the
airplane was late and then we're
supposed to go to New York NOP no let s
Us North Carolina yeah all that fun
stuff met a lot of fans did you guys fly
like uh private or whatever like [__]
not private like the pods like we they
missed our connecting flight cuz they
were late so they were like yo we don't
have no more pods left and like we do
but they're not together I'm like good I
I need to sit next to Rosie if we're on
a flight I don't want her not to be next
to me like some [__] happens you need to
be right next to
me also like [__] I was going a regular
seat if we're going to sit next to each
other like I'm good they had two left
but
like hey what's up what movie you
watching [__] this no I'm
good so we just got regular seats hurt
my back um that's pretty much it yeah
got back did a bunch of stuff I don't
know what oh Benny Benny the next
morning that's right that's right that's
right damn dude we've been on it
September was a long ass month my back's
been it's because I've been getting up
early and having to go to the doctor
every [__] morning every morning bro
so it's like I've been getting up and
actually going oh I have somewhere to be
[__] all right let me go but my back
hurts less so I'm like all right let's
go I feel so much better dude it's so
weird it's [__] crazy actually you
weren't filming so I just focused on the
podcast and that was really nice yeah so
if you see a bunch of new sponsors come
on the show guys make sure you go
support [__] and Marty Thomas
is [__] up
back yo these are pretty [__] good
um what the [__] talk I don't
know oh let's let's be like other
podcasters relevant topics here we go
hey man you hear about that new [__] man
oh man yeah I heard about that I'm going
to give it a a lid shut the [__]
up exactly thank
you
God I see so many Tik toks about people
talking about [__] and I
go like hot topics yeah it's always hot
topics but I see the same news story on
12 different shows back to back to back
speaking of Hot Topics big shout out to
[__] hip-hop DX big shout out
to [__] hot hip hoper and all
the [__] hip-hop sites writing all
the Articles who else and godamn
[__] Big Daddy [__]
Kane so Random hit us up on Instagram
today share the story was guys all right
[__] we talking about okay yeah hip-hop
DX put out the article about Benny
reacting to the him on drink Champs
which is really cool to see us like
right next to them up in these articles
and [__] now and then uh my boy DJ DJ
efn from co-host of drink Champs me and
him are IG buddies and Shar the [__] and
dm' us and [__] this morning good
[__]
um yo sorry sorry I got so
sidetracked super sidetracked I had
something I was just about to say
completely [__] lost it love it oh oh
oh
so from the podcast and from the dope as
Yola channel from
everything I was thinking about it
recently and I was thinking more
of the past two years I tried to all
right look at this what happened this is
what happened I saw these like
influencer dudes and I'm like yo that's
your editor okay
sick that's your manager dude oh oh
that's your your videographer okay oh
that's your this oh that's your you got
[__] oh and I got to stop
saying that I got to stop cussing so
hard cuz YouTube hates us and I got to
start speaking without having to cuss so
much because I feel like if I I say cuss
words as if I'm breathing and sometimes
I feel like it might be a buff buff and
I need to stop being a buffer zone and
start thinking and articulating my words
you ever like I was just sorry I was
thinking about YouTube like YouTube
views The Show by the transcript if you
sit there and read the transcript it's
insane the [__] that I say I'm a
dictator over here even the hex episode
I was looking at the transcript like all
right on paper this is a little
rough some of this it's the emphasis I
say on these mother I just it's like
it's like I [__] threw it into the oh
my God it's like I threw it into the C I
need to start being able to speak like
text over here is saying I can probably
handle business meeting like me too but
like four times the Fool's going to
laugh because I said something stupid
but like I said it on purpose man just
talk but then again that's the whole
point of the show but at the same time I
need to be able to do these things CU my
goal at the end of this life is to be
like yo Jimmy Kimble I know you're done
give me your show let me just get let me
just take your show I'm going walk out
hey did you hear about this yeah shut up
kick this fool out of here yo if i a n
late night show no celebrities would
ever want to be on our show nobody would
ever want to come to our show it'd be
like the Eric Andre show but like the
celebrities weren't in on
it they not fun for them theyd come on
like hey remember when you did that
thing why'd you do that thing no sit
down sit down come back well that was
Brad Pit that was Brad Pit guys thank
you for being here like oh so the show's
over nobody wants to be on your show
I'm basically be the Steve wil Coos I
bring you up so you can just get thrown
off shout out to Steve wil for being
such a bad TV host because I we were
just talking about this before the show
the [__] that doesn't get said on camera
I I crave this
[__] we are getting so much trouble all
you know
what I got a little light at the end of
the tone for you Marty
okay I think cancel culture is
over I think saying whatever the [__]
you want to say is coming back very soon
and I think racist and horrible horrible
horrible dark humor is going to be okay
again racist jokes are funny when people
make fun of meic people if it's funny
I'm a laugh not just cuz it's because
it's
funny that's that's like that's that's
all humans can only relate to what Being
Human what's the differences the way you
look well I'm going to make fun of it
because I can't make fun of anything
else but all right cool let's do that
[__] all right cool and we all roast
each other go back to fifth grade let's
all go back to fifth grade and just
roast each other again because all these
little [__] fools get every single
person that stands up for a race being
can being offended is never part of the
[__]
race everyone that's ever stood up for
Mexican pools are not
Mexican Marty all your cousins got to
knock it
off not you standing up for your cousins
because everyone that's ever been like
yo something something rights like I'm
not part of the group I'm just like like
shut up I get that you're trying to do
it but it's always you [__]
that make it annoying it's always the
fools that have nothing to do with [__]
that make it annoying so this is what
I'm saying to
you if you don't like stuff that people
say don't [__] watch it if you don't
like that person don't you don't have to
follow
him it's so that's it it's pretty much
it a lot of shows I don't like it a lot
of things people do I'm like oh my god
what the [__] and I
go oh yeah I forgot about it because who
the [__] cares you don't walk into
Walmart and go I hate this branded
clothes everybody I [__] hate this
branded clothes oh my god when I went oh
my God I was on Rodeo Drive and all the
people protested
Balenciaga like you give a
[__] yeah they're weird don't buy
it just don't buy it then if there's
like a a van with like a hundred kids
that gets discovered outside of blaga
and it's operation then we can storm it
get the strike going but you know who
doesn't know about any of this stuff the
people inside the building of Balenciaga
they're all paid to be there they're
worker protesting against fools at
minimum wage jobs doesn't stop
corporate in any way and I'm only
bringing Balenciaga because I saw that
protest it does nothing and all you do
is make like all the environmentalists
that block the road I'll fight you
no I'll [__] fight you make everybody
late to
work
[__] block the freeway Marty that's
insane to think about doing at least
three accidents happen because of them
at least three fan Defenders happen
because they're like stop oil I I drove
here I parked over there but stop oil I
drove no I drove my Prius here but still
I drove here like shut up you smoke
cigarettes how do you even do that how
do you get I don't I don't I don't it's
like some Frogger game that you don't
want to play out there Jesus
Christ I don't know I don't see myself
stopping I was going to do this one o
yeah damn I'm sorry you know also [__]
[__] exist we're going to be on this you
know what so back to what I was saying I
think Kaner culture is on the way out I
think people are saying I think bad
friends has opened up such a
door because they're ripping on each
other so open L and so [__] harshly
that it's like
hey can I can I say that [__] too hey if
I go with your show can I call him that
dude can I do that voice too to Bobby
Bobby Lee is just like he's
inadvertently like just opening the
world up again and Santino's back there
Stone Cold face saying [__]
going oh he don't give a [__] Bobby
don't give this is what we need open
roasting again mhm and I think bad I've
been watching a lot of bad friends so
I'm like yo you guys make make me feel
more comfortable going hey shut up you
know your mom swam here right you know
just stupid [__] I say that [__] all the
time I don't give a [__] but I know
you're not allowed to say on the
internet but if I had a mic in my hand
it'd be fine mhm so so what what I'm
trying to say is I think canel C's on
the way out Marty I think the hilarious
RW is back we got to get you rapping you
could say all the yeah the r word was
rapping
the hilarious rapping back there we go I
got to start a lonely island group so I
can say
whatever the r word I
want yo yo could you imagine you know
what the thing is I think if I was
allowed to say what the [__] remember
when we first started this podcast and I
went but but what if I said remember I I
had the structure I'm like but like what
if I say it like but can I say that like
but get in trouble that was my biggest
concern like are we going to get in
trouble I'm talking about a cat getting
decapitated check out the clips channel
for cat story time not on purpose it's
an accident but you killed the cat I
killed a butterfly [__] happens yeah
only one of us did it on camera you
psychopath it's
true I didn't even know there's a cat
under my hood in my car I had no idea
anyway I think it's back I think we're
getting close to South Park taking over
is there evidence making you think this
or is this just wishful
thinking I see a lot of bad friends I
see a lot of comedians saying what they
want and literally it's this bad to I
got to do this I see a lot of people
saying isn't that crazy I can't even say
the [__] word anymore it's not racist
or anything but it's like you're
Politically Incorrect you're supposed to
say mentally challenged like [__] shut
up shut
up and then just call him that right
after just walk
away yo when I was a kid being able to
call someone that was the Ender like
shut up fool like oh damn you ended
it and with me my my Bugs Bunny with
baggy clothes on on my
shirt with the big jeans that were
backwards yo crisscross [__] [__] up
in the
90s the original [__] influencers the
original Ray shmer for real wow criss
cross Jesus is Ray shmer still thing
yeah I think there's no music I don't
really follow mainstream music neither
does Marty so I'm shocked you even knew
who that was Marty they were going to
come on the show oh that's right all
right I'll take a little bit of credit
back just a little bit um so I think we
can say whatever we want again coming
soon and when it does you better be
ready I'm going to verbally assault you
and you guys tell us cuz we were talking
about this before the show patreon made
it now so that you can upload video
directly to patreon meaning before you'd
still have to host your [__] on Vimeo or
YouTube one of these other things Vimeo
kicked us off we would love to be able
to just freely post and just have the
followers that want to see it see it
without having an algorithm judge it and
then [__] put it out to who it's
going to put it out to based on its
robotic judgment of whatever it is that
we put all this time into that we're
posting so you guys let us know if you
[__] with patreon or not because it's
also they just partnered with Spotify I
think make it affordable like 190 bucks
an episode for each
person you about 600 bucks an episode
guys we put so much goddamn time and
effort into everything that we do and we
you know and it just sucks it's like you
know YouTube decides what it's going to
do with it either way but we'd like
to building out our team here get into
the position where we can start putting
out more 2024 let us know I feel like
patreon's ramping it up I feel like it's
the only thing that's really common to
people that they know about that's kind
of for the Creator where it's like how
Instagram used to be in the sense that
if I follow this person I'm going to see
what they post it's I want to see what
they post they they spend a lot of time
on this [__] they want me to see it and
to actually have that little tight
community of people so I would love that
I think it's worth investing time into
one way or the other but I think patreon
is the only like third party Standalone
site that's doing it the right way you
guys let us know if it's worth our
time
[__] see say whatever you want let us
know if it's worth our
time [__] or now you've had enough
[__] Bob Barker Happy
Gilmore um RP R damn yo I saw the
funniest thing ever is the 99 Cents have
we talked about that we talked about I
think we talked about on here Bob Barker
died in 99 and I saw the funniest tweet
I ever seen in my life tell this
[__] never went over a dollar no
matter what he did a
damn that's the that's the that's Peak
comedy right there wow you [__] me Bob
Barker and Betty White both die at
99 let's get one wide over 100 give us
one wide over 100 going for it I'm going
for it man my level income and the way
modern technology I don't see why I
can't live to 250 300 I got to go back
and really watch stepb Brothers Tyler
Knights they kind of blur together for
me it's kind of how like black sheep and
Tommy Boy are kind of the same movie I
feel you but I watch Black Sheep so
violently hard that Tommy Boy is like
a back burner in my brain it's the Happy
Gilmore to Billy Madison oh no no no no
those are those are equal anything under
2004 Adam Sandler is very level for me I
mean come on dude how many times we
gonna get into this H got water boy then
[__] then you got The Wedding Singer
Happy Gilmore Billy Madison qu your
[__] Classics Jesus
Christ that's [__] hard also here we
go my homie Anthony called me last night
and I missed the call and I called him
right back and he ran into my to Joe my
homie Joe
that was my homie Joe yeah Anthony ran
into Joe last night we I I mean like I
said I hadn't seen him in 10 years I saw
him on
Christmas um yeah he he's not doing good
but uh when I saw him he was doing cool
he when I talked about he was doing all
right is this the friend that you saw
walking down the street yeah okay yeah
um it's a trip it's a trip man CU
Anthony took a picture with him and he
sent it to me I go what the
[__] having a picture of Joe is the
weirdest [__] ever right mhm but like
you could tell is all [__] up but like
he's still very he's he's still there
he's still there I think in the general
sense of like internally you're just
like you're that dude that's who you are
but like even with me like I was say oh
yeah yeah we did huh cuz Anthony's like
he don't barely remembers this like for
real like [__] that's crazy and then we
talked to Joe's mom she's like yo he's
been missing I don't know where he's
been so thank you for you know sending
me the picture whatever um weird [__]
man I was thinking about all morning all
[__]
morning um cuz when you left when you
saw them you were kind of like here's my
number oh okay yeah compared to the
pictures you know when honestly that's
exactly how I pictured him to he looks
so he looks like he's he's smiling still
I mean that's not overstepping the line
if I show Joe I've never showed him
before I think it's cool that's totally
the world never forgave us for not
showing your
stepdad yeah this Joe that's what he
looks like
now this looks
older we've shown his kid pictures
before right
yeah does he know that you have this
whole world
up he doesn't know what the [__] we're
doing
it's a trip though because 10 20 feet to
the right is a story where me him and
Joe and the crackhead touched my [__]
hair when she had herpes on her face
damn who would have thought [__] 15
years later be like
damn so he's been gone for what 10 years
12 years yeah around
there I mean anthy lives in the same
town hasn't seen him in nine years oh
you know that's slider's out did pill
spiral and other [__] I would imagine or
uh I don't know man I don't know I
haven't talked to him enough but yeah
what a trip Anthony called me last night
like twice in a row I was like oh [__] I
got to answer this
[__] and yeah do
people kind of a stupid question
homeless people out there are their pill
addicts strung out like that's not like
the tweaker you think math you think
like all these outside so many MH a lot
of them smoke pills and then they start
moving on to sh because yeah because uh
maybe ble that too May that gets his AG
restricted
uh because the pills get too
expensive anyway it's funny the Benny
episode didn't get
AED or dided in seconds Benny The
Butcher and we're
talking I was a three Time Felon 30
years old don't do that was such a
gangster movie did everybody realize
that was a voice over to a gangster
movie that felt that's what it felt like
when he said that I'm like oh sh this so
hard nope but hex over here yeah I went
fishing in like you know idiots [__]
age restricted instantly like we're over
here talking about
idiots what the [__] we talking about
cooking crack
[Music]
cocaine oh
[__] anyway yeah blew my body
this is reminiscing guys so we haven't
been here in a minute so when he started
naming off those streets in South
Buffalo I was like what the [__] are you
talking about oh yeah my mom was texting
me as I was going I was like look at
Marty's
face I did not expect him to start
saying that [__] no the whole time
remember in well you need to go back and
watch Step Brothers your face the entire
episode was like in Step Brothers when
the dad meets will frell's younger
brother sitting there like you God
you're impressive
Don't Call Him son what it's my son
getting to know each other [__] that's
how you're
looking you look so [__] high I mean
bro come on we talk about this in season
that's like getting Jim carre's ass in
here how much we talk about one one day
that fool's going to be sitting across
from us and I'm going to go hey sit
still sit still you see that fake Rhino
would you mind crawling out of his
ass what if we had a fake Rhino on the
wall and that's how he came into the
episode but he didn't know he had to
come in that way that would be down he'd
be down I think he'd be
down going to get a [__] Rhino
[__] and stalled them with the wall
over season
4 hear me
[Laughter]
out to the right of you below
uhhuh we have someone's hand come
through Rhino's was asked to hand us the
sponsor oh someone else want you got
another joint all right cool it's a good
pitch hand hand coming out of a rhino's
ass Trent how much is it going to cost
no the rubber how much is the rubber
going to cost paint
it research a
Trent yo Trent just finished oh shout
out to Trent just finished his first
property his inspection happens
today today his first property he
rebuilt the whole [__] house himself
his sister's place no him and his sister
bought a house in
Fresno to fix up and ran out the [__]
is ripped the stairs out redid all the
walls did everything cut holes to make
doorway like he did everything dude so
shout out to Trent imagine building a
[__] house honestly dude the other
day like I put like there was like a
little shelf that I bought for between
the chairs in my room and you didn't
have to do anything no assembly and I
put it down and I was like
[__] yeah I did that [__] like d to put
nothing together and then TR build a
house no no you ever seen those Tepe
remember the Tepee and you seen Tropic
Thunder you've never seen Tropic
Thunder everything past 99 is a blur I
kind of have seen everything with Ben
Stiller and Jack Black no I know what it
is I act like I've seen it it's one of
those ones that I assume man you really
got oh it's so [__] good Marty that's
the last movie where you can say
anything you want I mean he did
blackface the whole [__]
movie MH great job at it though
um there's a scene where Ben Stiller gos
off by himself and he makes a little
fort Tepe where the panda attacks
him that's what I'd be living in if I
didn't know how to if I if if I had to
build houses I would be living under
half water draining into my house tee
yeah outside right by everyone else's
nice house because I don't know how to
[__] build give me six books and 30
years you're going to see me stack the
books of sleeping under the [__]
books in the ring because it's just not
going to [__] happen if you've been
following my Instagram story We
constructed a [__] gazebo in my
backyard recently and I had nothing to
do with that [__] yeah oh yeah he text
me he stepdad's out here [__] putting
the Gazebo together [__]
yeah every time he comes around he
builds [__] oh no no he texts me he text
me April stepdad just walked into a
cloud of white widow
[Laughter]
smoke all I imagine is you doing this
hey hey Marty smokes in the gr blew a
hit all right you want to talk about
trying to do [__] I bought a roll of ENT
I was going to try to T oh that's right
cuz I was going to try to tint my own
garage windows they're this big yeah
there's four of them they're small now
this man just built a whole gazebo in
the backyard by himself you know this
thing is like above people there this is
important it can't above people know
it's complex and he looks at the tent
and he's like I can't you you want to
get a guy to do this but he walked in
the garage and he walked over to the
[__] table to get the tent and as he
did I had just
fing right over like cuz the doors over
here the windows over here so I'm just
out there by myself I just sent this
giant Cloud right over at the [__]
garage door and yeah he came out and
just consumed that [__] you swam right
into that [__] played it off didn't say
a thing you know what you got to do I
think I just solved your problems I just
thought about it you ready I'm put the
joint down that's how important this is
this is like a little Vape you need to
pretend that you vape you need to start
having a little Vape in your pocket
around your kids have this little Vape
when the parents inlaw come over but
never hit it just like have your little
Vape around they all know I smoke
wheat what this concealing [__] I didn't
know I thought you been like I think he
knows I [__] smoke it wasn't funny
cuz it was funny cuz he just W he just
[__] was consumed by this [__]
Cloud you walked into I don't ever smoke
in front of him or talk about it or
whatever but it's like you know pretty
[__] obvious when you go out there
and the
[__] homies for Life [__] is out
there and all the you know just me
wreaking and [__] when I come back from
the studio I'm
editing Cloud behind
you no just getting uh getting this
[__] uh sponsorship done sound me and
my uncle John I was like
oh and if it's not me hacking it's you
on the [__] computer computer hacking
a lot of the time Marty's new monitor
has tracking and his monitor follows him
around around the room so sick it is the
creepiest [__] the first day I thought I
had [__] of sickness I'm watching
like why I realize I never stand still
when we're FaceTiming all day and [__]
cuz it's just subtly you just realized
this [__] Bobs and weaves 90% of
the time you start off like this that's
how you start the interview the
interview the FaceTime
Su you're doing this 42% of the time no
so much the first time I think who was
it I think it was uh John the first time
he ever watched the pocket he
goes Mar used to rap or something I go
yeah what he goes like he's like he's
moving like he's dropping verses I go oh
okay I never thought about it that way
yeah he
does yeah he
does so no that's how it
is um I got that standing desk gives me
confidence yeah that's right he has the
standing desk and the [__] monitor
moves of course you're doing that [__]
surpris you're not playing raet ball
like a prisoner
right sorry forgot what the [__] we were
talking about to get I have no idea what
we were talking about oh The Cloud of
weed smoke uh yeah I'm pretty I try to
be pretty you know I'm so lowkey about
it that [__] was pretty [__] funny to
me and just cuz he's like the whitest
dude all time You' never like took a rip
off the White Widow pen I did get April
to T I sent
you I'm in midf fight and I get a video
and the you know when the intro to
videos just where it started so it's
just like a freeze frame and it's this
and Marty's holding his
hat and it starts and him
just cackle
laughing zoom over April I
snuck I was like hit this hit it do it
she actually and she just did it and I
was like do it till it blinks 10 seconds
he made it blink the [__] white widow
pen she could she didn't even [__]
come
close of all
things the one I say is like yo this
one's [__] St she's going to hate it
oh it's so [__] funny to me and then
you sent me another video and I was like
here is her I'm a
throw there was like four Clips I got
five [__] Clips in a row I was trying
to listen to him at the fight and I just
hear I'm a [__] thop I was going to
post it and I'm like Maybe not maybe not
I can't be you
know going back and forth with parents
and principles and [__] all goddamn long
and but you can but you are Blan yes you
can [__] him yeah I guess so [__] him
all right [__] him who
cares their kids like oh I watch that
show like oh hey can you tell my kid to
not be such an [__] to me on the show
it'd be really cool like nope cuz you're
a [__] and then you tell the kid back
run from home and you come me here and
when they call him tell them you're not
here I'm just trying to think of
horrible things to do to parent I have
no a you have a laugh moment oh I know
what you were doing man D I touched my
eye with weed before we started and it's
just you usually save that for the ad
reads I usually do but I hit myself
right when I was mid rolling joints all
right and shout out to all my daughter's
friends that I end up on a FaceTime with
and are all stoked about the show that's
funny if I could give you guys more
merch and [__] I would but you know it's
got bongs all over hold also if you ever
run into my little brother Johnny do not
[__] pay him a dollar don't give him
anything my little brother has been
charging people and he'll [__]
FaceTime me and go see told you it's my
brother oh no way big fan and he hangs
up like Johnny what the [__] it's like
this guy believe me said he give me $20
and I did he did it twice to me already
my brother's [__] 10 hustling people
out there how many brothers you got a
lot you keep there's always a new one I
don't know about I know he the youngest
he's the last one little bastard called
me when he was in Mexico cuz one of his
cousins friends didn't believe it he's
like that's my brother he's a YouTuber
like that's not your brother I'll call
him right now he's like I'll bet $20 and
then he's like the guy gave me $20 it's
a tight move I mean like Johnny don't do
that to my fans [__] up dude yeah and
I even told him like Hey don't you give
my [__] brother anything cuz he told
me in the second time like don't you
give him [__] I was like don't be doing
that [__] to people [__] you're
not Cameo you can't do that that's not
cool also like you call me seven times
in a row I think something happened to
somebody you got to stop doing that to
me dude don't call me seven times in a
row he did this [__] to me during the
[__] show I [__] was like oh my
God oh my God but he just you're just
some random [__]
he doesn't even know also was like
Johnny what if someone's like yeah oh
your brother smack the [__] out of him
or something or what they don't like me
like yo this your brother I don't know I
don't know people are weird but also
like that's some [__] [__]
charging made $40 off of people little
[__] I mean when he's 20 it's going
to be a funny story but like don't do
that [__] it's [__] up man uh yeah
anyway that's what's going on that's
what's going on in that world
so what's the plan with the dopa Zera
Adventures channel for 2024 okay so here
we go guys that's what we were talking
about earlier oh my God and I started
off with
cancellation and people being able to
say what they want that's my point I'm
going to act like I just brought it back
that was my point on the maps we would
did this yeah yeah you see on the on the
maps of movies they're like oh you went
the wrong way and they go back to the
map that's us on conversations but
usually nobody ever tells us
The Rock I thought the Rockies would be
more Rocky than this that never happens
in our conversation so we just never go
back we just keep the money in that
sense what fck everything is a Jim
Carrey reference at the end of the day
something always goes back what you say
550 Grand GNA want to hang on to that
one oh oh yeah that's right that's right
the
lambo oh that expensive in the '90s
disgusting the dope as Yola Channel
ready oh that's what I was saying I saw
these guy he's got 12 this he's got a
guy for this he's got a guy for this
he's got a guy for that's what I was
trying to say earlier oh my God that was
to
day
so I've been trying to be too
professional I've been trying to go I
only film Wednesdays I only film this
day oh no I only post on this day nope I
this hour is set for this that hour is
your side for this that [__] doesn't
work in the in the world
of weed drugs and
smoke no I can't say drugs I do drug
drugs anymore in the world of weed
smoking
content okay there can't be that
schedule anymore doesn't work cuz you
know what that means if I can't get that
done right there all wait till next
Wednesday to put that out what does that
mean it takes a week to [__] get it
back for the edit two weeks out what
happens if I miss it twice a
month so now my video is a month back I
can't be doing this [__] no more so
that's why I'm like I got to stop being
so professional I have a nice camera I
can film myself sometimes I can do these
Vlogs and I have to wait till Wednesday
when I have the videographer I can
[__] do these things and I just don't
because I'm like no no I I'm past that I
can't be filming myself anymore that's
not what I do anymore I'm like but why
not the [__] wrong with
you so that's why that [__] last
baked everybody loved it like yo I
[__] love these I filmed it myself M
the whole thing yeah POV turn around on
myself and like that's how I started
doing [__] so I got to I got to do more
of that I'm going stop trying to be so
[__] stupid professional and not
everything needs lighting I can go do
[__] and doesn't have lighting like I
just I keep thinking like I have to be M
I have to do this but I don't we need
way more clips of dop dope as Yola [__]
yes yes uh 100% because there's two
channels I'm actually talking to one
there's two channels on Tik Tok that are
called dope as clips and dope as Yola
fan they post my story
times with half me and half gameplay on
the bottom there's millions and millions
and millions of views on these multiple
videos
[Music]
mhm I can't even post my own [__]
because it gets flagged because I'm
smoking in it but these fools have cut
around the smoking
MH I'm about to hire one of these dude
but he'll make me just a shitload of
Clips bro because sometimes I'll be
watching him like oh that's me like Damn
I [__] I remember this story damn I
think about the per like wow what the
[__] that was a long time ago and wait
million views [__] that's great but like
I can't even put this on my own channel
[__] man so I'm about to hire one of
these FS to make me clean Clips so I can
just put them on my [__] cuz they're and
I mean they're all crediting I mean
they're like yo this is not dope as Yol
this is dope as Yol fan Channel MH like
you guys are so good at making these
clips just give me pay you do it for me
yeah because you're doing it right now
for free do it to get paid yeah by the
person that you're posting that's the
way to do it that's how I started my
whole Graphics career yeah showing
people sick [__] yeah of course um but
uh I've been trying to be too
professional right I'm just going to
start doing [__] like how I used to do
it just [__] run it let's just do it
film it [__] it let's film this SM how
many times I have I would have hundreds
more videos if I filmed how many times
we smoke five gr [__] Ros and Joints
not ever even to post a picture of it
99% of the weed [__] we do we don't even
film it because I'm like oh no no no no
I have Nik here no I'm not even miked up
no let's just [__] smoke like bro
just filming your phone man help this
good content right this is some sick
[__] like John roll is the dumbest
[__] hash Hol I've ever seen never
even filmed one mhm ever smok six gr
Hash Hash holes with six grams of
hash didn't even take a picture like
what's wrong with me I try to get two
professionals is what happened guys I
try to be too like well he's got five
dudes we got you know Marty and I got my
videographer I'm the rest of it yeah no
I don't have the videographer I'm not
filming [__] that [__] oh you're not
ready oh we got to push it back to a
different day [__] I got a the same
camera
M Fu let's get the shotgun mic here we
are yeah so that's what I've been
thinking and also the adventures of Yola
is no longer it's now called Adventures
of Thomas go check it out Adventures of
Thomas um I'm just going to post my
YouTuber [__] on there I posted the car
full mayback review it did pretty
[__] well I haven't posted in eight
months and I had people in the comments
like why forgot I follow this channel
like [__] that's not good I haven't
posted in eight months might as well be
a new new channel so that's what's going
on guys the adventures or Adventures of
Thomas no more Adventures of Yola cuz
they linked it to dope as Yola and
flagged me for a weed or flagged me for
a drug paraphernalia
account uh not monetizable even though
all my videos are green and they say
take down the videos that are not
monetizable we monetize you but all of
them are green what the [__] do I take
down they're all familyfriendly so I
think the channel just got Associated so
anyway that's what's going on vengers of
Thomas um don't your old Channel 100%
Going back I just gave Marty two videos
um to edit also we got another person
finally helping us out we're bringing on
he edited the last video his name is
Henry shout out to Henry he edited the
[__] out of our last video um he's
yeah he's doing a good job man and we we
need help guys like Marty I told him
today when I was getting my back [__]
done I our biggest downfall is we
don't put out enough of
ourselves
small content like small Clips shorts it
takes so much time if we had someone
just pumping it out somebody could have
been done for eight Clips already while
we've been filming this episode instead
of Marty rushing back to do eight clips
and then rushing to do a dope video and
then doing and then cramming it all
together and they like well [__] dude
I'll wake up at 5:00 and get this done
like [__] Terri that sounds terrible
so that's what we're doing right now
we're trying to expand the team as he
was talking about earlier but expand the
team in a good way so he did the full
video by himself no edit from Marty he
took over that one full edit [__] ton of
footage a lot of [__] footage 12
hours worth actually on three different
cards imagine having it's not even like
having a it's like a you got
a big giant block of cardboard that you
then have to make the puzzle pieces out
of and then put the puzzle together
that's what it is when you get a giant
batch of it's like getting the cardboard
and none of it's in the right none of
it's putting the shapes together got you
got to size it unpackage it look at it
and then puzzle piece it it's like oh
two more steps sick how many times you
touch one piece of a clip is like
five imagine there's 5,000 Clips because
here's the thing if you want to get
really
insane when you start considering how
many frames are inside of a clip at 24
frames per second and then you think I'm
responsible for every frame in this
[__] every frame in this video
needs to be deliberate and it's there
100% you know like and I can't leave
anything out I need to make sure I found
all the best moments so that we're not
leaving anything on the table cuz just
understanding what's in the footage is
big can be overwhelming and then to take
from it what you want and then what to
keep and to tell a story is a whole
skill when I used to do it with one line
mhm so I would throw all my b-roll like
30 minutes out so they wouldn't get next
to my other ones and be a gap of 30
minutes MH and then I have to
unscrolling it freeze every time time
you
scroll so it's like seven times longer
than it should be well guys it when we
got our first new sponsors we got me a
new computer with a beautiful display so
like thank God I was editing all that
[__] on a laptop up to this point so I
can see what I'm doing now and the [__]
is moving nice and smooth and definitely
we keep just reinvesting into the
quality of the show but that's why also
when you see all these new sponsors
coming on and we're really shout out to
Raw uh trying to give you guys sponsors
that you want and that you know are
meaningful to people's lives you see
them come on please support them it's
the only way the show works but we're
heavily active in the community right
now and I'm thinking for 2024 there's
going to be a lot of cool new sponsors
coming on the show you see that go hit
them up and say what's
up exactly what time we at
Marty two two
hours did not feel like it
at all I couldn't even tell you what we
talked about today that's how L yo
sometimes we had a [__] FaceTime
conversation should have been 40 seconds
just to send information it was [__]
30 minutes earlier we need a we need a
weekly show man we need a weekly show
besides just this or another episode
that's just us even if we put a solo out
we need that solo on Friday or something
we need something I feel like we have so
much [__] FaceTime Friday FaceTime
Friday
type of
[__] we had something with that stereo
app before that [__] went all sideways
what if we did live stream M me and you
co live on a Discord so it doesn't get
messed up MH and we just save the
footage and put it straight onto no
editing just put it straight onto
YouTube as like FaceTime Fridays that's
the only way something live like that
like a 45
minute [__] those facetimes are the
goofiest silliest sh but also that's
when see a lot people just do goofy [__]
stop doing goofy [__] me and Marty won't
talk about it sometimes sometimes you
see that [__] like that guy's [__] up
man hey you see what like I did not all
I mean not sitting there call like you
[__] up I'm saying like when people do
[__] up it's like oh that's when our
FaceTime calls
go yeah I saw that after we're done
talking about this [__] let's talk about
that because that was wild people just
do stupid sh [__] a
lot and it's funny it's like how Rogan
commentates UFC we commentate on stupid
[__] we see and we're not to talk about
podcast we're talking about Earth
Welcome To
Earth family friends everybody applies
everybody if you're doing stupid [__] oh
yeah I got the [__] Cherry Springer
news before we even started this [__]
yo sometimes people just you know kids
say the darnest things we need that I'm
GNA reinvent that show because
Bill Cosby is not GNA be part of this
kids say the darnest things need to be
adults do some dumb [__] I forgot he did
a kids show that is so creepy oh I
completely forgot he did and it's not
like he was like the spokesman for the
number one kids food of all time
either I just remember just I didn't I
forgot that pudding pops I would [__]
kill your family I was 5 years old for a
jell PUD P he was dosing people with
[__] though
you man this is how we got to stay you
can't start doing Bill Cosby talk
because then because then they're going
to be like hey hey we already don't like
you talking about meth don't be talking
about Sir Bill Cosby now and things he
did remember when you grabbed a bunch of
gummies was like oh here just EA some
out of the bag now they're all over the
table and [__] you already know what was
about to happen I didn't I had no
idea oh my God
all right yeah I eat these bored hash
things for breakfast lunch and dinner
one big handful right down the hash that
sounds
horrible um guys I got to be
honest I came in here
today I had no direction I just knew
like you know there's no guest can we
please just call people a [__] or
something can we please just say stuff
and
also I've been watching a lot of Comedy
enforcement still
that page the channel is awesome comedy
for does a lot of podcasting
stuff people are [__] up people are
doing stupid
[__] and I I mean I I think the first
time we ever got a video age restricted
is when we talked about the certain
comedian remember that yeah that's the
first time we ever got age restricted
ever mhm was when we C when we talked
about SMI
mmia we talked about that guy and his
allegations that turned out to be true
um the first time we ever got AG tricked
we talked about a certain famous
comedian's allegations isn't that
insane that's when we started getting
agct you know it's the first time ever
season one sixth episode in eighth
episode and it was like a wholesome
episode too right it was wholesome
besides that that was the how we met our
wives episode ironically yes it was it
was um so anyway like it's hard not to
you know what I don't give a [__] they
can do whatever they want I don't care
but I I do see a lot of people still
work with certain people that did weird
[__] and it's like yo what do you do
what do you do if you're like yo I know
what you did they're
lying all those people are
lying I know about this one um yeah
anyway that's what's been going on also
uh get Shane gillis's ass on the show
everybody go tag his ass I he needs to
be on here we need to be making fun of
each other cuz is just too funny shout
out to the 10,000 people that responded
to our Instagram post for who they want
well comedian too Shane Gillis was
heavily he was one of them uh when we do
that guys that's a big way for us to get
guest so thank you for you guys got
fluffy for us thank you very much that's
how we got fluffy you guys tagged him he
came hitting us up directly in the post
in the comments thank you guys um yeah
besides that we just wanted to catch up
man just wanted to catch up and see how
you guys are doing want to let them know
who we got coming on the
[Music]
show didn't we talk about it earlier I
don't think so no we were supposed to
have flight reacts yes we talked about
that flight Rea was supposed to be here
today but he did not show up today so
whenever he comes on the show he comes
on the show we also have coming up very
soon Ralph Barbosa which is going to be
very sick um upcoming comedian which I
think is awesome because that is what
say every rapper wants to be a comedian
every comedian wants to be a raer oh no
basketball player rapper right is that
is that what it was something like that
it's like damn
you're doing stages and [__] this's
crushing it i' me I've seen a lot of
people request him too yeah funny [__]
we're working on Mexican OT I had guys
all right there's two things we get
messages about 30,000 times a day number
one we know people are ripping off push
trees thank you guys for creating
awareness about that it's brutal what
they're doing t-u fuing push trees okay
thank you but we get messages about that
constantly number two we're daily trying
we're working towards getting not daily
but a lot getting Mexican LT on here
we've done everything we can do I'm not
the we are not the fools to go hey hey
you know be really
sick we're going to ask you a few times
we'll follow if you want to go yeah but
no we're not this like the please please
please we're it's this I do solo right
now we love doing solo episodes love Mex
to be here you're supposed to come
couldn't make it in time supposed to
come didn't make it in time it's not
like we're pushing it off that's what
what we're trying to get at when they
get the time they'll get the time Benny
was supposed to happen eight months ago
we're not going to be like yo come on
man you said you would do no when you
have the time you have the time when xot
has the time he'll have the time we're
not going to be sitting your push we
talking to his managers we talking to
his people man trying to be a fan so
when it happens it happens we're not
going to sit here and Bug bro if you got
the time you're going to come that's
what she
said and there's another uh day one
guest that I I'm just going to
mysteriously allude to who is locked in
without a
date oh oh who is I'm let you this a
little bit cuz guys this man can knock
you asleep by staring at you this man
can bite an a pendant job this man will
knock you asleep by staring at you did I
say that already yeah I did he'll disarm
you with a ice cold s
hey everybody you want to eat mushrooms
that's what I hope we get for walking
through the door I hope we get the champ
post champ of you guys want to eat
mushrooms like kind of I do I kind of I
do yeah Mike Tyson locked in coming
officially coming to the dop podcast
Tyson's officially coming to the [__]
show see the transcript goes and he said
[__] very hardly bold underline it
208 if it's 2 I'm lose my [__] 210 damn
it anyway got Tyson coming guys damn I
don't know how I was like who are you
speaking of there's not a date attached
to it guys I wasn't even going to bring
this up but we're fully locked in into
the [__] so we'll see about to start
levitating I know I feel like I want I
forgot about the [__] for a minute it's
a big
deal start levitating right
now you remember that kraar I think it's
all right the video where he's walking
down the street but he's not walking
he's kind of floating over the street
and he's just moving mhm that's that's
how I feel when you were like titans's
locked in I was like yeah and I floated
up my stairs yep there was a couple
moments last week where I was in my
garage like [__] flexing see Marty's
in his
garage every time April walks
in hit you in the stomach where where
that mesh is let me [__] blow smoke
in your dad's
face stupid I can only imagine the
nicest man ever just getting
clouded coming out to evaluate the ENT
tint earlier sounded like he said tits
so for everyone out there coming out
here to evaluate the tit did you just
say about your [__] father-in-law
tint window
tint um oh okay also one more
thing it made me really re-evaluate my
life again I tried my best to go out of
my way and say hi to people and oh God
all you people are just not saying hi
back this sucks
then we were out we did the fan oh we
flew out Julian and Milo Julian 40 420
Julian won the golden ticket for the
dopa shop.com three months ago he just
couldn't get it out couldn't come out in
time he was doing too much [__] so we
did it this month we flew him out from
Chicago we got him in the van took him
to the restaurant we got high went weed
shopping went to the grow Top Golf you
know just like a day of getting high
with us that was the whole point of them
when they won the golden ticket and they
already make YouTube videos M like and
everybody's like yeah right they won I
mean one person won you just got to
bring a friend somebody won that month
one and the guy was such an [__] we
decided not to do it anymore he
basically said [__] you and your trip
give me a
PlayStation I'm went oh maybe we should
ask people anymore if they want to come
out here what if we just get more
psychos anyway we opened it up again and
that's that's who won I remember the day
I got the DM like wait I've seen your
face before oh you've done a he did a
review on the dopus before people really
think we set that [__] up like yeah he
won like
hey this is the now the the 10th month
we just decided to try again [__]
fans are going to win of course they're
the ones that are buying this [__] but
the fact that he went is pretty wild
dude cuz him and his fan both buy so
it's like he had two chances yeah you
know anyway we brought him out and John
John's like the most talkative person on
Earth talks to everyone on Earth and
make friends with everybody I'm the
opposite I don't say [__] to nobody if I
don't know you I think it's just from an
age of like oh there's the other gang
bangers and then there like I go home
home with my mom my sister [__] are
here so it's like you it's F my sister's
on the other side of the wall my
sister's here for everybody get her on
the show probably never happened bro
probably just argue for [__] two
hours so anyway
um John's talking to all these people at
this the table next to us and I I was
like I got to just say words I said I
finally said words to the people next I
was like oh yeah we do this and this and
this and this blah blah blah
blah like it's not too bad not too bad
we're doing all right we're doing all
right and then my doctor I don't tell
anybody what we do I told you that if
people ask me I've go to my doctor five
times a week it's the sixth or fifth
week
now I to I would be honest and say that
we talk we've talked and we like we talk
about stuff like we're sitting there for
2 hours doing the procedure stuff and uh
I don't tell nobody what we do I'll say
nothing I say we have a show I like [__]
say nothing oh I just do like production
yeah for podcast oh no not like
comedians or anything just like [__] you
never heard of like health and [__] I
always say I just do production I don't
sell nobody nothing they Rec like you
wear this brand a lot go yeah I just
want call company but oh it's yours like
yeah yeah a long time ago I bring up
something else cuz I don't want to go
into it cuz most people are like oh it's
this weed look this F smoking [__]
weed on the internet like and then they
I come back and there's a different vibe
that doctor piece of [__] [__] from her
said [__] me up dude she scared me I'm
like I can't treat you if you smoke
marijuana when I when I broke my [__]
when I actually ended up breaking my
vertebrae it's so stupid how did I do it
I don't
know I wonder whose comment I was typing
when I went oh my God that [__]
hurt um oh um [__] anyway sorry the
reason I'm bring it up my doctor walks
in like a week ago and he just opens the
door and goes you didn't tell us you do
a show like just like you didn't say
anything he's I've watched four episodes
already hooked instant fan my doctor
right he's like I would have never
guessed on Earth I would have bet my
life that you don't do anything in
involved with talking cuz you don't say
anything it's like you're the quietest
person ever I was like yeah man like if
you talk to me like I'll talk but it's
like you don't say
anything but you talk you talk on the
show like you're a different part that's
what I say and I went I got to stop I
got to stop
this I got to just talk to people I know
this is like I say this on the talk show
sorry but if I don't know you I a going
to say a word to you mhm that's it
people recognize me I'm so talkative
because I'm like oh you already know who
I am you know that I'm a nice person
you're probably [__] nice cuz you
even came up to me and said something
like what's up different it's a it's
different right off the bat right it's
like a little secret club like oh you
got the oh what's up it's different M um
but I just need to talk to strangers
more not strangers to people I can say
what I do anyway he said it 12 times
like I can't believe you talk for a
living yeah he's like don't say nothing
he said it like that like damn you're
right I don't say [__] to no one and and
then then cuz uh one of the girls that
works there I guess was getting picked
up by her boyfriend is like what the
[__] is that F like that's Thomas like
why do you know Thomas like comes here
and then they came in the whole office
like oh she showed everybody my [__] but
anyway the doctor's a fan so shout Dr R
he [__] loves this stuff
but the reason I'm saying that is like I
went home and I'm
like that's not good that's not good
that's not good MH
because that's not I'm not I don't know
this is this is me but also quiet ass
fool like this in the corner mhm it can
be you too that's me too but I got to
stop stop just being this [__] dude
because I'm afraid that people are going
to be dicks and I'm going to punch him
or get upset does that make sense I got
to stop thinking like that last night I
was taking my sister in and out and
there was like five or four uh dudes at
like 20 I walking back to my car and
like what do you do what do you do to
get that what do you do how'd you get
that I
go um I just do like uh like you know
clothing clothing stuff like oh you sell
cloes you couldn't sound sketchier when
you do that when he says like what do
you how do you do that what do you like
what do you do for work how did you get
that what is that I was like uh I just
do clothing stuff
man because if I go I'll do YouTube
they're what channel
instantly which is fine but I always
feel like people are going to be [__]
dicks I don't know why I gotta get over
that [__] you can call yourself a
host podcast host that's a nice clean
thing people accept yeah I guess so but
then it's the show and then once you see
the show you see everything yeah but I
can't see the clothes you the website
you see everything but I can't see the
reup you go oh you're in the weed
industry but I can't see the do oh
you're in the weed industry your face is
on the
website it's the weirdest dilemma man
dude I got to stop being in the dma just
let it go because I mean everywhere I go
something people like yo what's up man
hey what's up I'm at work I'm at work
exactly it's like Fight Club yeah most
people like yo not work but [__] that's
how they were in the Bahamas of dudes at
work they like yo I can't really say
much cuz I but like love your [__] oh
hell yeah was it really illegal there no
not the weed not the weed like that they
were just they can't really like so like
talk to the guest and be talking to them
like cuz they dudes that are running the
this or doing this or doing they're not
like supposed to sit there and take
pictur he's I want to take a picture so
bad but I'll get in trouble there
cameras everywhere I like oh don't worry
man my last day as I was [__] in the
river I [__] hopped out cuz he was on
the side I took a picture that some
there picture me just
saw [__] shirtless and [__]
sunburnt was some dude Chris um yes
that's Chris
uh yeah anyway so as they were saying
that I was getting in my car I was like
yeah you you do what did you just say
clothes and I was like yeah marketing
stuff like oh okay give him no type of
[__]
Direction I feel more like I was being a
dick if their eyes now like that guy
didn't want to tell us what he does he
must do something that's the I never
thought of the other end but I was just
getting my car I was
like the [__] am I doing I got to say
something I got to stop doing that man
and this morning I dropped my car off a
Mercedes my [__] mayag is leaking oil
in my [__]
garage sorry I just had to say that
there's a puddle of oil bigger than me
in my [__] garage when I got back
home damn oh my
God sorry that really pissed me off I
brought it in here's another example I
brought my car in this
morning and I'm in the in the offices
I'm just looking at every [__] dude
there
like come around all the guys that work
they're kind of like oh [__] obviously
you don't see you don't don't see that
kind of car right
often but one of the dudes shout out to
Eddie Eddie works he's like and he's
like you dude from the dope you a
podcast I'm like oh [__] yeah what I
never always say it like that that was
awesome anyway this
like uh like the like the like the woman
that's that gives Robbie Hart meatballs
and The Wedding Singer for singing
lessons like that age of a woman super
nice white lady I guess super I At first
she looked mean but I'm standing by the
car and she walks up like oh my God this
car and I goes oh yeah it's it's it's
awesome she oh this is yours I was like
yeah it's mine I was like oh man what's
coming next the way she said oh this is
yours I'm like what are you going to say
next all I kept thinking was are you a
driver who bought this for you did you
steal I was like damn what are you going
to say with the way she said it I was
like what I feel like something mean's
coming next and then no she's like yeah
it's beautiful blah blah blah blah wow
I've never even seen this this is a
Mercedes and she did the whole Spiel
he's like oh yeah what do you do I was
like
oh marketing and I did it again this
morning Marty three hours ago I did this
and then I went right to my back doctors
my back is freshly popped um I did it
again I promise I I was it a month and a
half ago I was like I'm trying to get
over this thing come on kid get over it
and then I was like I got to go back to
New York
and I'm just going to I'm going start
talking like that all right
Marty yo welcome back to the dope as
usual podcast we're here to talk about
[__] Lucy chop cheese and lighters
you like
that the dementos that come down suck
the soul out of your out of your body in
a
night see what happens when Marty's not
sitting here I just try to like buffer I
try to buffer zone nobody else in
podcasting none of you other
[__] are getting up and
changing your own cameras like Marty is
right now all right let's just throw
that out there I'm buffering and doing
New York
Voices I do voices uhoh hot dog or was
it this is my impression of a hot dog
Missed Out Fire when he's trying to get
a wow job
placement no that's a those details like
but you remember when he's trying to get
job placement like I do voices what do
you mean you do voices yes and he starts
doing all the goddamn [__] was
funny and once again the algorithm just
picked up [__] imagine a Robin
Williams episode hey don't do stuff like
that to me that's [__] up mhm cuz you
can't I know it's sad who's our top five
people who have died that we would have
like oh my God I don't want to go down
that road that seems so
sad we already said I mean obviously DMX
Tupac these would be epic EP episodes
come
on come on who's the first guy that
would be shaking his hair out of his
eyes that I want to sit down with what
Chris Farley yeah of course Chris Farley
be sitting there oh yeah so so what is
oh phone what is that kind of thing like
this is [__] iPhone man yo this is
sad I don't want that's that's [__] up
I just started thinking about that and
that's [__] up no no no no that's
weird that's weird that's like [__] you
do in
dreams that's true
God we had Will Sasso was the closest
thing you Kennedy somebody hey let me I
want to get your voice down yeah no
you're totally not relevant anymore but
I want to get the voice down just talk
all right nobody gets I do bad voice
impersonation that'd be it that's all I
get out of Kenedy like who shot you but
no no no no talk you sound like mayor
quinby from you know from Simpsons a
little like what do you mean no you
sound like M we bit him wow everybody
out of there like yo what is this guy
talking about and everybody over 24 go
in oh gotcha yo The Simpsons go back and
watch The Simpsons we're putting a lot
of younger fools on some good [__] go
watch the [__] first 15 seasons of
The Simpsons watch this [__] with a
notepad it's good it's good [__] man um
what was I going to say what the [__]
were we talking about sorry we talked
about how sad it would be to interview
people that oh God you were talking
about the meeting the fans in the
Caribbean is it Caribbean or Caribbean
dude I say Caribbean and then I say
Caribbean half the time it's like saying
mayback Maybach yeah I feel like dumb
saying one way and dumb saying the other
way no one said [__] nobody said the
word Caribbean the whole time no nobody
wanted to say good morning back maybe we
could had a conversation but no nobody
wanted to say hi back to me [__] Jer
oh back to what I was saying yeah yeah
yeah the kids last night I was like
marketing and I got back in my car and
drove off like a [__] [__] so I
got to start talking even though all
right guys we're we're we're all growing
together okay so what did we get from
the
story my back is getting better I'm
going to be two inches taller at the end
of this [__] I swear to God if you
count up all the millimeters how many
millimeters are in an inch can you
check are you wait how many millimeters
are in an inch am I going to get taller
for real I've been making this joke for
a [__] month I've been making this
[__] joke it'll be 6'2 at the end of
the
[__]
uh 1 inch equals 25.4 mm oh [__] no I'm
not going to grow in any okay I got five
oh oh how many millimeters are I got a
five a five a four a four a four a three
four twos what does that mean like 5
millim another 5mm disc that's out of
place 5 millim oh so that's 10 14 18
that's four discs right there mhm I have
15 discs out of place okay and three
more or three so that's nine more I'm at
29 mm I'm going to grow over an inch if
they all go back if they all go back to
place like they
should there some science right
here it's going to start
levitating I know you never seen Lost
Boys but the song from Lost Boys is
going to start playing as I [__]
start
Rising I'm going to rise and my hair's
going to grow long as
[__] I really thought is that a scene
from the movie cuz I'll
spend 30 minutes trying to find a frame
of what you're talking about no I was
just imagining it and then I was
imagining uh Bruce Almighty for some
reason but no no that's just that's Mark
Ekko in the mid 2000s remember all the
shirts of Mark eeko the guy was floating
or doing something
spray yeah you guys remember all you
[__] remember everybody that
wore big Dickies back then you guys know
what the [__] shirts I'm talking about
anybody that wore a Ben Davis outfit
ever anybody that's ever wore Cortez's
knows exactly what the [__] I'm talking
about
we didn't have Ben Davis or cortezas but
we had have Mexicans 5x Dicky suit yeah
you had no Mexicans yeah we you have
black fatigue jackets and [__] that you
guys wore 5x because it got so cold
sometimes you but yo get in here like yo
it's freezing out here
kid swear to God I don't ever want to be
in that kind of cold but maybe I do or I
just get
taller everything I always say I got
taller yo I woke up this morning taller
yo I'm gonna get out of this back thing
over an inch taller that's pretty funny
that's a good testimonial could you
imagine if I go back and a eye level
with Mar like yo what's up man I grew 4
inches uhuh Chevy Woods comes back for
episode two you guys are just eye to eye
now no I'm looking at the top of his hat
knocking L like you some lint on the top
of your head kid let me get
that looking down on could you guys IM
sorry we're over here just ranting [__]
I'm sorry back back issues go fix them
if you uh have back issues 100% please
if you've ever done anything or taken
any advice from anything we've ever done
go look at
decompression don't look at spine fusing
don't look at screws don't look at back
surgery please yet please go look at
decompression um I don't know what the
procedure is called but it's the table
and it pulls my hips it's not an
inversion table and you're not hanging
you're flat and it's pulling your hips
at a certain degree for each vertebrae
for each disc so I swear to God guys I
couldn't even walk in August for a
couple days the other day I bent over
and I haven't bent over and grabbed
something and got up without having to
hold my breath or stick my knuckle in my
hip so it doesn't pop or doesn't like
get out of
place
bro big one yeah putting on my shoes my
my shoes are tied in the middle I don't
know I know you never noticed this look
down they're tied in the middle they're
usually tied right here cuz I can't bend
over far enough so I have to just try to
get them where I can cuz my back's so
bad [__] but now I can bend over and tie
my shoe properly damn it so if you ever
seen any videos my shoelaces are always
really really close to the inside cuz I
can't my back get stuck I didn't realize
how many things I can't do because of my
back is nuts D I can do them but it's
just not fun over time you just become
like debilitated and you're like [__] I
didn't even realize
crazy dude my whole time every time you
ever SE me on my every time I've ever
been on camera my back is crushing a
little
more you did this n for real though all
those meat and greets definitely flared
all this up that's when I crushed my
[__] Arch yo
my I need to take more vitamins I don't
eat enough food that's what I'm saying
this fat guy said he doesn't eat enough
[__] food I don't that's why I just
like I feel like uh Daria you remember
ARA of course that's how my body feels
with motivation inside all day yeah yeah
it's going work
out that's how I feel like flopping to
the bed at all times but I know like I
got to get up I'll smoke more OG guys
I'll smoke more Ina I need to wake up
never works anyway yeah that's what
happened guys I'm my body's is getting
better I got to start saying my back
sucks my back doesn't suck my body's
getting better cuz this this [__] sucks
yeah um all right now I got to get in
shape running marathons we get sponsored
by Hoka come on Hoka give us a check and
a bunch of sick shoes cuz I got a bunch
of hokas they work I wore Hoka shoes the
other that's when I know how much my
back hurts I wore [__] Hoka shoes out
and I was not going to any part of
exercise and that's why I look down like
oh my back's
bad cuz I don't give a [__] I'm going to
wear vans and then now I'm wearing Vans
I supposed to but I put my Ares in them
this morning so we're good guys sorry
we're over here talking about how bad my
my back hurts um yeah so I don't know
what else we've been talking about we've
been talking about a bunch of [__] if
you're still here thanks cuz this is
what our FaceTime turned into just
talking [__] usually way more explicit
but we're going to figure it out guys um
above all right now do us a huge favor
follow us on Spotify dope as usual on
Spotify that [__] to 100K we're almost
do 100K on Spotify which is awesome
[__] sick thank you guys so much over
you think you want likes comments All
That VI where they tell them on
Instagram wherever I don't know let it
be
known tell your neighbor YouTube's got a
monopoly on this and it's not cool cuz I
need you to go tell your neighbor but yo
YouTube's got a monopoly on our [__]
homies out here I know you don't have a
computer Miss
Chon but they got a monopoly on these
fools go follow them on Spotify you need
go tell everybody tell people that don't
SP English about you Spotify all you
girls out there they got like four dudes
trying to hit on you tell them to go
follow us on
Spotify that's how you're going to crush
it thank you every girl out there that
watches our [__] that has a bunch of
dudes trying to hit on them be like yeah
yeah I'll give you my number if you
follow the [__] fools on Spotify
catch me in the comments I'm I'm kidding
but yo if you did that [__] that's a
good way to support that's pretty
sick hey and we're not just eliminating
all the dudes out there they got a bunch
of dudes hit on we're not we're not
limited anything tell them to go follow
on
Spotify and buy a bunch of me medium
shirts because we have a lot of mediums
right now everybody use your looks and
tell people those kidding tell your
[__] parents what was
that sorry it was like a they said to go
go get your parents credit card oh
crusty the clown sorry we're going back
to the Simpsons over and over and over
apologize take it back it was crusty
when he was selling he was selling stuff
guys let's continue cuz I'm very sorry
if you're still keeping you here if
you're still here thank you very much go
follow us on Twitter all right dope as
usual on Twitter our Instagram go follow
our Instagram dope as usual podcast
correct correct yes I one of them had
podcast on the end of that [__] Tik Tok
dope as usual boomman 1 point something
million likes damn near three four
months
now thank you we're at like 70 something
80,000 almost all platforms are at 100
which is crazy also Facebook is just
it's over a 100 thank you guys so much
all you fools out there that actually
like our Facebook thanks because there's
some crazy ass [__] out there dudes
and chicks [__] whoa the girls do
drugs more videos doing really good
right now yeah yeah that's a fact yeah
and uh it's funny the ones that that
really go they really [__] go on
Facebook and it can happen later on I
might sit for two three weeks and now
it's shot up to 350 now how bad is it
though when I said girls do more drugs
no it wasn't a controversial one no more
people like agreeing I think I don't
really I sit there and read the the most
sexiest thing I ever said and now
they're like yeah it's good me talking
about something I didn't even have no
part of but you're a piece of [__] why
are you on
Facebook I hate you it's okay though
it's okay it's all right but also the
clips channels [__] boom thank
you Clips Channel dope as usual podcast
Clips maybe we should change to like
dope as usual
Clips no because it's dope as usual
podcast on in on YouTube also MH we're
keeping it the same never mind yeah no
there's just going to be nothing but
more content coming out on that in 2024
for damn share dope asusual podcast.com
super proud of how the site's looking
right now Marty made a brand new website
go check that [__] out and coming 2024
Marty will have his course out we're
trying to figure out how to do it still
but it's coming all right so if you're
out there and you're you know
what we we've talked about it but you
already know all the stuff the full does
is not just sit here and get high with
me there's a lot more of stuff it's a
lot more technical [__] what would you
call it graphic
arts digital media digital media there
you go digital media all right go check
it out go check out Marty's Pages Marty
made it on Instagram um yeah oh push
trees got hacked the other day yeah [__]
push tre's Instagram got hacked we found
out who push tre's Instagram got hacked
and within 10 minutes of them hacking it
it was already on the dark web for sale
my friend went to go see if you can find
it already ready for sale on the dark
web and then we found a bunch of DMS
they were getting erased as we were
reading and when we got back in this F
in another language telling asking
people to buy it from different pages
changed our bio says if you own this
page please DM me at this like these are
some hackers we got it back MH back in
an hour because we also have a hacker
dude it's not me by the way no if it was
we would just Hack YouTube and go hey
let let them by paid monetize them def
[__] them yeah there you go def [__]
them
Reflow all right let them not be [__]
constantly by us because you you know
what no that's what's getting us within
10 seconds you said YouTube [__] you and
you suck within 10 10 seconds of a span
keywords [__]
you yeah maybe that's what's getting us
also yeah okay um so yeah go go go
follow all those accounts guys we're
doing all as much as we can we're doing
everything we can right now have a lot
of stuff coming lot a lot of cool
sponsors coming and thank you guys for
being here it's been a long episode but
I think we needed it and it's just a
rant episode which is totally totally
fine the the uh title is going to be why
Yola hates leaving the
country the TR true true American but
you know what we needed it it's a
cleansing I'm getting taller literally
literally finally how many times have I
said that God I'm just getting taller
you wish that manifestation I'm going to
get taller I don't know how I'm going to
do it but it's going to work all right
what else what else what else what
else I need $100 million doll check from
somebody but it's going to be for
something really good and not like
something I don't approve of and it's
going to be really sick and then
everyone's going to be hyped and I'm
going to get to keep at least 50 after
Le 60 after these taxes and then I'm
going to put 10 into something to make
me [__] 40 pack and I'm be crushing
it that's how these things work mhm what
I say I want the car to get messed up
enough just to where I have to get a new
car but they cash me out still because
it's not my fault but I also don't get
hit that hard to I get really hurt and
you're also not in the
car is that where I broke my
vertebrae when that [__] hit and run on
me sorry I've been trying to figure out
when this broke remember I got the
[__] Whiplash hella hard when was the
doctor
2014 the blue car no in my my my Impala
and then I got the
[Music]
money oh 2014 yeah uh is that when I
[__] could be sorry I've been trying
ever since it told me like your [__] was
broken at one point like what fractured
like yeah it was bad it's healed but
it's there like what when but years for
sure every time your head just snaps
back real quick no because that's where
my shit's [__] up at
yeah like it's still out of place I can
feel it it's crazy being able to feel
that my disc is not
[Music]
sitting imagine sciatic pain when people
get the on the leg but up here it's down
the arm MH so it's still the same
sciatic pain it's but it's on the arm
it's the weirdest feeling ever and it
shoots to right here so I'm like am I
have heart attack oh no it's my neck God
it's so worse dude I wake up ow let's
get out of
here [__] ah all right here we go guys
thank you so much for being here we just
sitting here talking appreciate you for
being here Marty anything else you want
to say appreciate you guys this was nice
checking in it's been a minute I feel
like it's been a minute guys uh I was
thinking the other day maybe we should
be more topical maybe we should talk
about more stuff I think we should bring
back segments a little bit like we used
to what's good segment this I can't even
remember these I can't even remember him
what's popping what's good what's
[Music]
popping movie talk we had like I need to
go back and watch the first we had like
a bunch of and then we were like why do
we even do this was this talk about what
the [__] we want to talk about but also
it keeps us in track it keeps us in line
it gives us a little structure because
like I said I will talk here for 40
minutes and hurt my neck constantly by
violently hand gesturing
so yeah guys thank you so much for being
here if you're still here drop a like we
appreciate you thank you so much um I
think that's it thank you so much for
being here this is the dope as usual
podcast we have talked about life drugs
problems accomplishments and my
[__] back guys thank you for
being here from Marty O'Neal and I have
a dope ass day nice yo oh it's 420 on
the
[Music]
dot
perfect
[Music]